hello everyone welcome to this
interesting video on cryptocurrency full
course
in this video we will explore all the
important features and concepts
revolving around cryptocurrencies and
will also come across some of the very
interesting facts and figures about them
starting with understanding what
cryptocurrency is
then we will explore some very important
and popular cryptocurrencies according
to market cap starting with discussing
facts and components about bitcoin
followed by how to mine bitcoin after
which we will understand what ethereum
is and will explore its upgrade as well
as how we can mine ethereum after that
we will have a comparison between
bitcoin and ethereum then we will
explore our third crypto dot coin
and its various components like those
coin mining those coin wallet and its
comparison with other cryptocurrencies
then we will jump into the other side
and explore some of the other popular
aspects of cryptocurrencies like nft
solana and shebainu coin we will then
conclude this video by discussing the
recent downfall of crypto market by the
end of this video i can assure you that
you will have thor knowledge as well as
a clear picture of cryptocurrencies and
crypto market
for this training with me i have a
experienced blockchain specialist rahul
together we will take you through the
various important keynotes of
cryptocurrency
so let's start with an exciting video on
cryptocurrency full course
before we begin make sure to subscribe
to our youtube channel and hit the bell
icon and never miss an update from
simply learn
meet frank and daniel
one day they decide to go for a trip to
venice they made a budget list for all
their expenses like residence flight etc
they thought of making their bookings
online from a site that offered
discounts to the first 10 visitors on
that day
while making their respective flight
bookings daniel's transaction failed and
he missed the offer going on
on the other hand frank paid his share
very quickly and easily and became one
of the three lucky draw winners
daniel was surprised and asked frank how
he could make the transaction when
daniel himself could not
to which his response was it's simple i
used bitcoin a type of cryptocurrency
daniel was confused and he asked what
cryptocurrency is and since when has it
been in use
frank stepped up and explained to him
cryptocurrency is a virtual or digital
currency that works on blockchain
technology and is designed to work as a
medium of exchange online to buy goods
and services and make payments which was
introduced to the world first in 2013 by
satoshi nakamoto
daniel felt that it sounds similar to
other online payment options he asked
what makes it so different
frank explained cryptocurrency is
decentralized and free from any
third-party interference which means it
is not issued and controlled by any
government or central authority unlike
other payment systems that banks or
governments are handling and that's why
a cryptocurrency transaction never fails
there could be many reasons for why
daniel's transaction failed like he may
have exceeded his transfer limit for his
account must have been hacked or there
could have been some technical issue
with his bank server or maybe due to
high transaction fees imposed by the
bank
but on the other hand cryptocurrency
charges almost no or very low
transaction cost there is no limit for
making transactions
in fact you have 24 7 access to your
money there is no extra delay or extra
charges on making international
transactions and the best part is that
anybody can use cryptocurrency without
the hassles of paperwork
all you need to do is create an account
on any digital wallet of cryptocurrency
this is what makes cryptocurrency
different from other online payment
options
daniel was impressed by cryptocurrency
but he wondered how it works without the
control of an external authority
upon research he found out that
cryptocurrency works on blockchain
technology
blockchain is a set of blocks that
record information of transactions like
who made the transaction to whom the
amount of trade in the form of a digital
ledger that is distributed across the
entire network meaning the data is
replicated and stored on each node
across the entire blockchain network
making it more secure and impossible to
change hack or cheat the system
then it is verified and validated by
every node to proceed with the process
of making the transactions
the crypto in cryptocurrency stands for
cryptography which is a method of using
encryption and decryption to secure the
data in the presence of any third party
with ulterior motives
now daniel was completely aware of the
whole technology and concept behind
cryptocurrency and was influenced by
frank to adopt cryptocurrency in his
daily lifestyle too
he did that by booking his ticket but
sadly no discount like daniel
cryptocurrency has influenced and
impacted an enormous number of people
worldwide
due to this increasing popularity new
companies like metoo and paypal are
coming forward and investing in
cryptocurrency every day in 2018 malta
an island located in the mediterranean
sea south of italy was titled blockchain
island as it led to the economic
stability of the nation
many fintech companies like binance and
okcx have already begun to take
advantage of malta's financial
incentives and have moved their
headquarters to the blockchain island
so here is a question for you
which hashing algorithm does
cryptocurrency use
a
script
b
ethash
c
sha256 d
none of the above
please give it a thought and drop your
answers in the comments section below
three lucky winners will receive amazon
gift vouchers
cryptocurrency is revolutionizing
finance and banking around the world
thanks to cryptocurrency now anyone with
an internet connection can trade spend
and borrow money around the world and
nobody can stop them
people like bill gates co-founder of
microsoft corporation and elon musk ceo
of tesla support cryptocurrency as it is
much better and secure than physical
money and also holds a great future for
the world's economy
and on the other hand some people think
of cryptocurrency as a bane to the
world's economy like warren buffett ceo
of berkshire hathaway and ajay benga ceo
of global mastercard feel that
cryptocurrency is a platform of criminal
activities and will destroy the world's
economy
well one thing is clear that this
conflict is going to stay put for a
little longer hi guys today we're going
to talk about 10 things you didn't know
about bitcoin firstly we have the
mysterious creator now in 2009 a person
or a group of people known as satoshi
nakamoto introduced bitcoin to the world
he vanished off the internet in late
2010 he hasn't been heard from since now
just like his identity is shorter than
mystery nobody really knows if he's even
alive or dead the only communication
people had with him were through emails
and forums his bitcoin wallet holds
around 980 000 bitcoins which makes him
one of the richest people on the planet
next up we have the satoshi now as a
sign of respect for the bitcoins creator
the smallest unit of a bitcoin is known
as a satoshi one satoshi is valued at
around 0.000
669 for us dollars which is a very very
low value now to make one bitcoin you
need approximately 100 million satoshi's
now according to the current bitcoin
values which fluctuates a lot to make a
dollar you need close to 15 800
satoshi's losing bitcoins losing your
bitcoin address which is also known as
your private key not only means losing
your unique identification it also means
you lose all the bitcoins in your wallet
research shows that at least 60 percent
of all bitcoin addresses are ghosts
which means a huge chunk of the
population that's using the bitcoin
network have lost their addresses now
these are the people who have lost their
addresses and have no way to access
their wallet liberland now in april 2015
a micro nation between croatia and
serbia known as liberland was born now
this was founded by virgil a politician
publicist activist and the president of
liberland now the official currency of
liberland is bitcoin now the government
took this move believing that bitcoin
and its underlying concepts of
blockchain provides a secure and
transparent method for recording
electronic financial and physical assets
processing power the process of mining
bitcoins is a expensive process now you
pay a high torque to do this like your
money your time and electricity now
mining bitcoins require servers that are
used for that specific purpose alone now
the faster you process the data the
faster the block can be added to the
blockchain and the faster you're
rewarded with bitcoins power consumption
now just imagine how much electricity
ireland consumes in a year approximately
5000 kilowatt hour now how much do you
think all the bitcoin mining farms
together consume 60 terawatt all which
is approximately 6 into 10 raised to 10
kilowatt hours which is a large amount
of power now the entire country of
ireland which is the second most
populated city in europe and has 84 421
kilometer square of area consumes lesser
electricity than all these farms
combined bitcoin ban now although
several countries around the world like
canada and america have wholeheartedly
accepted bitcoin there are some that
haven't countries like bolivia iceland
bangladesh and ecuador have completely
banned the usage of bitcoins there are
also countries like india thailand and
iran who ask their residents to be
careful while using cryptocurrencies
they haven't completely banned it
however they do not accept it as a legal
tender law limited number there's a
limit to how many bitcoins can exist in
the market this number is capped at 21
million bitcoins as of this moment 17
million bitcoins are already in
circulation to give you an idea that's
almost 80 percent of the 21 million
already done but don't worry until 21.40
we'll still have bitcoins to mine this
is because of how miners are rewarded
now miners are rewarded with 12.5
bitcoins for each block added to the
blockchain and every four years the
reward reduces by half the next halving
is supposed to occur in 2020 where the
reward reduces to 6.25 bitcoins the
power of b the terms bitcoin with an
uppercase b and bitcoin with the
lowercase b mean two different things
the only thing that differentiates the
two into two completely different things
is the letter b the lowercase b in
bitcoin refers to the cryptocurrency
that is used to perform the transactions
the uppercase b in bitcoin refers to the
ledger that stores information regarding
these transactions faster than
supercomputers the world's fastest
supercomputer the summit works at 122.3
petaflops which is nothing but a
quadrillion floating point operations
per second now if you take the bitcoin
network completely into consideration
the processing power is about 80 million
704 290 petaflops but the only thing
here is that a supercomputer can do
several different things but the only
thing the bitcoin network does is add
blocks to the blockchain let's talk
about what is bitcoin mining so what is
bitcoin so let's take an example so
there is someone who wants to send five
bitcoins to rachel now we will see how
this transaction can happen now bitcoin
is based on the concept of digital
currency anyone across the globe can
transfer amount in bitcoin irrespective
of the geography from anyone to anyone
so basically you need to just open an
account on the bitcoin network have some
bitcoins in it and you can transfer it
either you can purchase the bitcoins
online through some exchanges or you can
mine it so once you have bitcoins in
your account you can transfer it to
someone you want whose address you have
now do you want to know how this
transaction work well this transaction
is done by bitcoin mining so we will go
deep and understand that
how the bitcoin transaction works what
all entities are involved behind the
scenes in order to maintain the sanity
of the bitcoin network and make sure
that whomever you wanted the bitcoin to
reach to has reached and there is no
loss of bitcoin in the network and it is
a successful transaction so let's
understand certain basics so what's in
it for us today we need to know what is
bitcoin we will understand the
underlying technology blockchain so we
will talk about that then we will see
what are the advantages of bitcoin as
compared to other digital currencies and
other digital technologies then we will
go into the concepts of bitcoin mining
then what is bitcoin mining and we will
do a demo on certain aspects of bitcoin
mining now what is bitcoin bitcoin is
the first decentralized digital currency
that allows users to transfer money
peer-to-peer without any intermediaries
like banks governments agents brokers
nothing is involved and all this is done
using blockchain technology so as we saw
in our previous example two parties
wants to exchange money transfer money
they don't need an intermediary now
bitcoin can be used for online purchases
e-commerce transactions it can be used
as an investment instrument and it can
be primarily used for payments to buy
goods and services now it was created in
2009 it came into existence by a person
or a group of people called satoshi
nakamoto now bitcoin helps transferring
of assets faster than regular fiat
currencies it has definitely lower
transaction fees because as it has
removed the intermediaries from between
the cost of transaction also goes down
and it is cryptographically secure it
uses cryptography infrastructure and
thereby the identities of the sender and
the receiver are also secure and entire
transaction is cryptographically signed
and the users information who are doing
the transactions or are part of the
networker is also hidden and secure now
what are the advantages of bitcoin so it
allows fast and quick peer-to-peer
transactions it is impossible to
counterfeit or hack the transactions
which are running on a bitcoin network
and it's an overall decentralized
process there is no centralized body
which is controlling the transactions or
charging a fees in order to validate the
transaction it is the participants in
the decentralized network who are taking
care of the sanity of the network
thereby making sure that the overall
transaction cost is low all the
information is accessible to public it
is available publicly on a public ledger
anyone can go and view the transactions
and the volume of the transactions
happening on the bitcoin network and it
is a low fee transaction it is
comparatively low to other mediums and
channels through which today digital
transactions are made now what is
blockchain so bitcoin runs on the
underlying technology of blockchain
blockchain is a public distributed
ledger in which transactions made in
bitcoins or any other digital currency
are recorded in a chronological order so
let's see certain features it is
cryptographically secure signed using
your private key and then shared on the
network with the public key it is
immutable any record or any transaction
added on the blockchain cannot be
modified or altered it is run by a
decentralized system there is no
centralized authority on the body and
the transactions are stored in
containers aggregated in containers
called blocks so a block is the smallest
unit of a blockchain which records all
the transaction a basic structure of a
block is something like this it has four
fields these are the primary attributes
for block it has something called as
previous hash so the previous hash
attribute stores the value of the hash
of the previous block and that's how the
blocks are linked to each other data
this is the aggregated set of
transactions which are included in this
block so these are the set of
transactions which were mined and
validated and included in the block
nonce so in proof of work consensus
algorithm which is used in bitcoin nonce
is a random value which is used to vary
the output of the hash value so every
block is supposed to generate a hash
value and nonce is the parameter which
is used to generate that hash value and
the proof of work is the process of
transaction verification done in
blockchain now hash is the resultant
hash value obtained by passing the
previous hash value the data and the
nonce through the sha-256 algorithm to
generate the hash of this block so this
is the digital signature of the block
which is generated and this is the
basically identity of this block now
sha-256 is a cryptographic hash
algorithm which produces a unique 256
bit alphanumeric hash value for any
given input and that is the unique
feature of this cryptographic algorithm
whatever input you give it will always
produce a 256 bit hash now let's
understand the concepts of bitcoin
mining what is bitcoin mining bitcoin
mining is the process of verifying
bitcoin transactions and recording them
onto the public blockchain ledger in
blockchain the transactions are verified
by bitcoin users so basically the
transactions have to be verified by none
other than the participants of the
network those who have the required
hardware and computing power and those
entities are called miners so we will be
talking about them later but the point
to be highlighted is that there is
nothing like a centralized body as in
case of legacy transactions where we
used to be dependent on a regulatory or
governing body or a bank to make our
transactions go through now in bitcoin
here any user with mining hardware and
internet access can take apart that kind
of computer can be a participant and
contribute to the mining community
process is solved based on a difficult
mathematical puzzle called proof of work
so every miner's job is to solve the
mathematical puzzle which is called
proof of work in order to validate the
transaction and earn the reward and all
the miners as they are competing amongst
themselves to mine a particular
transaction the miner who first solves
the puzzle gets the reward now users
trying to sell the puzzle as i said are
called miners they are the participants
in the network who have the necessary
hardware and computing power to do all
the transactions to validate the
transactions and validate it they are
called as miners now in order to
understand bitcoin mining we need to
understand three major concepts of
blockchain it is based on distributed
public ledger it uses sha 256 encryption
algorithm and proof of work is the
underlying consensus algorithm for
bitcoin mining so distributed public
ledger a distributed ledger is a record
of all transactions maintained in the
blockchain network across the globe in
the network the validations of
transaction is done by bitcoin users
called as miners sha-256 now blockchain
prevents unauthorized access by using a
hash function called sha-256 to ensure
that the blocks are kept secure they are
digitally signed their hash value once
generated cannot be altered now
shk-256 it takes an input string of any
size and returns a fixed length 256 bit
output value and that is the primary
feature of shf 256 encryption algorithm
you give any input it will always give
you a 256 bit output and it is a one-way
function you cannot derive the input
reversally from the output what you have
generated and third is the proof of work
in blockchain mining is a process to
validate transactions by solving a
difficult mathematical puzzle called
proof of work now in order to do that
the primary objective of the minor is to
determine the nonce value and that nonce
value is that mathematical puzzle that
miners required to solve in order to
generate a hash which is less than the
target defined by the network for a
particular block now in the bitcoin
network users trying to solve
mathematical puzzle are called as minus
now the puzzle is solved by varying a
nonce which produces a hash value lower
than a predefined condition which is
called as the target miners verify the
transactions and add the block to the
blockchain when confirmed and verified
as of today the miners who solve the
puzzle gets a reward of 12.5 bitcoins
now once a block is added to the
blockchain the bitcoins associated with
the transactions can be spent so once
the block is validated then the transfer
of bitcoins associated with the
transactions aggregated in the block the
transfers are made then from one account
to the another now in order to generate
the hash let's see you use the sha-256
hashing algorithm you define the hash
value if it is less than the defined
condition the target then the puzzle is
deemed to be solved and if not then you
keep on incrementing nonce value and you
repeat the sha-256 hashing function
passing on to the nonce value and you
define generate the hash value again and
you keep doing this process till the
time you get the hash value which is
less than the target now let's check an
example so for example beyonce wants to
share 10 bitcoin with jennifer now in
order to do that what will be the steps
so beyond transaction data is shared
with bitcoin users the miners from the
memory pool the transaction goes and
sits in a memory pool of unmined
transactions so in a memory pool set of
unmined or unconfirmed transactions wait
until they are verified and included in
a new block they remain in that
unconfirmed transaction pool now miners
competing to validate the transaction
using proof of work they keep on
continuously pulling the unconfirmed
transaction pool they pick up those
transactions and start validating those
transactions
they aggregate in a data block and start
validating they start solving the puzzle
the miner who solves the puzzle first
shares his result across the other nodes
the other set of miners now once the
block has been verified the nonce has
been generated then the nodes will start
granting their approval if maximum nodes
grant their approval the block becomes
valid and is added to the blockchain now
simultaneously the miner who has solved
the puzzle will also receive the reward
in the meanwhile which will be of 12.5
bitcoin which as of today stands at 98k
around dollars now the bitcoins the 10
btc for which the transaction was
initiated now will get triggered and
will get transferred from beyonce to
jennifer now let's take a look at
certain facts in proof of work a
predefined condition the target is
adjusted for every 2016 block which is
approximately every 14 days and an
average time to mine a block is 10
minutes so basically the target keeps
automatically adjusting itself to keep
the block generation within the 10
minute time frame so this is the
representation so in order to keep the
time frame for block generation within
10 minutes the target keeps on adjusting
itself now the difficulty of the puzzle
changes the target changes depending on
the time it takes to mine a block so
this is how a difficulty of a block is
being generated it is the hash target of
the first block divided by the hash
target of the current block so this is
the difficulty which is being changed
after every 2016 blocks so basically it
is very hard to determine the puzzle for
other miners it is very easy to verify
what you have done and once they give
their consensus the majority then the
block gets validated and gets added to
the blockchain now since the difficulty
depends on the hash target its value
keep on changing after every 2016 block
as i said and as you can see in due
course from the day of inception of
bitcoin in 2009 till today difficulty
has increased exponentially and it has
been increasing and thereby the entire
effort of mining and the computing power
is also increasing so as of what was the
resources which were required to do
mining in 2009 you require more hashing
power more computing power in order to
do the mining today now what if someone
tries to hack the data so let's see
blockchain is a chain of blocks abc now
each block has solved a puzzle and
generated a hash value of its own which
is its identifier now suppose a person
tries to tamper a block block b and
tries to change the data which is
aggregated in the block so if the data
of the block will change the hash value
which is the digital signature of the
block will also change thereby it will
corrupt the chain which is subsequent to
it basically the blocks ahead of block b
will all get delaying because the
previous hash value of block c will not
remain valid so in order for the hacker
to make the entire blockchain valid for
the block b which he has changed he has
to change the hash value of all the
blocks ahead of block b which will
require huge huge amount of computing
power which will be next to impossible
so as you see the results in the
following block being invalid so with
this whole thing the blockchain is
making sure that the entire sequence
remains non-hackable and prevent data
modification now let's see what are the
underlying hardware requirements for
bitcoin mining and how the hardware is
evolved so in the early days miners used
to solve the puzzles using regular
processors the controlling processor
unit cpus now but it used to take a lot
of time for mining though the difficulty
levels were low but still it used to
take a lot of time now as i said the
difficulties level keep on changing and
growing so the miners also had to
increase the processing power so this
discovered that graphical processing
units gpus proved to be more efficient
than regular cpus so but this also had a
drawback of consumption of electricity
so any miner who has to calculate the
return on investment on the hardware he
also has to accommodate the cost of
electricity and other resources which
are going in in order to do the mining
so finally as of today
they are using a hardware called asic
application specific integrated circuit
which was specifically introduced for
mining which consumes less power and has
a higher computing power and a better
hardware for mining so miners are
profitable when their cost of resources
to mine one block is less than the price
of the reward they receive so definitely
they have to have the investment less
than the reward what they own so as of
today in blockchain miners use their
resources to verify a transaction they
each time a block is mined new bitcoins
are created in the network so the
bitcoin total supply is limited it is at
21 million dollars approximately 21
million bitcoin are in supply 17 to 18
million bitcoins have already been mined
so only three to four million are left
as of today a reward of 12.5 bitcoin is
given to the miner on doing the
transaction verification but the bitcoin
mining reward goes by the huffing
principle the reward given to a miner is
half every 210 000 blocks which is
approximately every four years so then
after that threshold is reached the
bitcoin reward will go down to 6.25
bitcoins so let's take an example of a
lottery ticket where your chances of
winning is difficult so we are talking
about what is bitcoin mining pool your
chances of winning the lottery is
difficult but in a community if
individuals buy multiple lottery tickets
and pool their tickets together then
this will increase their probability and
chances of winning more so suppose you
won the lottery then based on the
contribution the reward is distributed
among all the participants bitcoin
mining pool is a similar thing it's a
process where multiple nodes share their
resources together to mine a block now
when a block is solved the miners split
the reward equally based on the amount
of processing power they have invested
so it takes the pool members to generate
a final hash value then it checks how
much amount of work was contributed by
each pool member and as a result the
bitcoin reward gets distributed
proportionally amongst the participants
now let's take a look at a demo on how
can you see what is the bitcoin reward
now this is a actual block of the
bitcoin network as you can see this is a
block and
this is the block reward 12.5 bitcoin so
this was a block which was mined
this is the block number and
these are the set of transactions which
were part of this block now once this
block was mined by the miner all these
transactions then be done these are the
transfers of bitcoin from one account to
the other this is the nonce which was
generated by the miner or the mining
pool in order to mine the block and
these are the other attributes
and if you take a look at this url this
is an example of a mining pool it's a
demo account where the participants have
shared their mining resources and they
are mining it in a pool and see this is
the reward for which they are mining
this is the unconfirmed reward this is
the confirmed reward this is what they
have already validated and this is what
they have earned so far
so these are the hash these are the
block numbers which they have in mind
ethereum and its concepts
ethereum
simply put while bitcoin is defined as
digital money ethereum is a
decentralized platform that runs the
smart contracts exactly the way they are
programmed without any downtime fraud
and third-party interference and also
has its own cryptocurrency called ether
ethereum aims to enable innovations in
three key areas
currency assurance through ether which
serves as an innate currency for the
ethereum blockchain decentralized
autonomous organization
smart contracts
features of ethereum
the first feature of ethereum is that it
is secure because it is almost
impossible to tamper with the
transactions in the block or to add any
fraudulent blocks in the network
the second feature of ethereum is its
community following
ethereum has attracted a lot of
attention from people all over the world
the third feature of ethereum is its
corporate friendly structure
the platform is being leveraged by a
number of corporates to test and build
various applications
the fourth feature that we will take a
look at is the possibility of creating
new assets on ethereum blockchain that
can be used as currency
a representation of an asset
a virtual share
a proof of membership or anything at all
the next feature is the ability of
ethereum to process the transactions
fast while bitcoin requires a block time
of 10 minutes in ethereum it's only a
few seconds
the last feature that we will discuss is
the fact that ethereum is uncensored
ethereum's open source network allows
complete transparency to view every
transaction
all right that's all about the features
of ethereum let me tell you about an
important concept in ethereum called gas
gas in ethereum
gas is the fundamental block of ethereum
ecosystem that is paid for every
operation performed on the ethereum
blockchain
it is the crypto fuel for ethereum it
can be considered a transaction fee
which has to be paid when one party
sends ethers to another party
even when a person deploys a smart
contract on the ethereum blockchain a
transaction fee needs to be paid for
that as well this payment has to be made
regardless of whether the transaction
succeeds or fails
gas price is expressed in ether and the
miner decides whether to refuse the
transaction process or not based on the
expected gas price
one can see their transaction fee in eth
or usd when searching for the
transaction on etherscan.io
when somebody refers to gas they are
either talking about gas price or gas
limit
the total cost of a transaction is the
product of gas limit and gas price
the gas limit is defined as a limit
since it's the maximum amount of units
of gas one is willing to spend on a
single transaction
this avoids situations where there is an
error somewhere in the contract and you
end up spending a very high amount of
gas
however the units of gas required for a
transaction are defined by the amount of
code executed on the blockchain
lowering the gas limit below the amount
required will not help much
if enough gas to cover the computational
resources of the network is not supplied
with the transaction
the transaction will fail due to an out
of gas error
so
gas is a commodity which is essentially
a cost of using the system like bitcoins
ethereum also has its currency which is
called ether
ether
it is an incentive that the client of
the platform pays to execute requested
operations it ensures that the
developers write error-free codes
because unnecessary codes will increase
the cost
ethereum is a blockchain based platform
and ether is the cryptocurrency that
fuels the platform it is commonly
denoted as eth
let's have a look at the differences
between bitcoin and ether
bitcoin versus ether the first
difference is in the hashtag algorithm
used by these cryptocurrencies
while bitcoin uses sha-256
to encrypt blocks of blockchain
ethereum uses eth to encrypt blocks
technically both are one-way
cryptographic hash functions
the second difference is in the use of
bitcoin and ether
as we have discussed earlier bitcoin is
only used for financial transactions
like purchase and sale of goods and
services
however
ethereum being a touring complete
platform also supports smart contracts
and decentralized applications
the third difference is in the price of
the two cryptocurrencies
currently the price of btc is
approximately 3 500 us dollars while
that of eath is approximately 100 us
dollars
the market cap of btc is almost six
times greater than that of btc even
though eth has a higher circulating
supply
the fourth difference is in the vision
behind creation of these two
cryptocurrencies
btc is a currency created to compete
against the gold and flat currencies by
acting as an alternative however eth is
created as a token to facilitate smart
contract deployment and operations
lastly the transaction speed of btc is
much slower than eth
while btc's transaction speed is
measured in minutes eth is just a few
seconds
like bitcoins ethers are also stored in
cryptocurrency wallets
let's understand what are wallets in
ethereum
ethereum virtual machine
ethereum wallets a wallet is the place
to securely store ethers and other
cryptocurrencies
basically a wallet stores the means of
accessing your currency using the
private key
now that i have told you about the
ethereum and its currency
it will only be fair that i explain evm
now
evm
ethereum virtual machine abbreviated as
evm
is an engine which executes translation
code
smart contracts are compiled into
bytecode which an evm can read and
execute
the ethereum virtual machine can be
regarded as a quasi touring complete
machine
it possesses its own programming
language known as the evm byte code
once the code is written in higher level
programming languages the code can be
compiled to an evm byte code
the ethereum virtual machine uses a set
of instructions called opcodes to
execute specific tasks thus if a user
triggers a transaction of 5 eth using
his desktop wallet the wallet sends the
message to the evm which connects with
the wallet address on the ethereum
network to process the transaction and
send it to the receiver
smart contracts are written in ethereum
specific programming languages
let's learn more about these languages
ethereum languages
every contract written for ethereum is
compiled into the evm byte code and
deployed to ethereum blockchain for
execution
ethereum uses the following languages
the first language is solidity solidity
is an object-oriented high-level
language used for implementation of
smart contracts on the ethereum
blockchain
solidity was influenced by python c plus
plus and javascript
it is designed to target the
evm the second language is a low level
lisp like language
abbreviated as triple l it is one of the
original ethereum smart contract
programming languages and is similar to
assembly it is meant to be a very simple
and minimalistic language essentially
serving as a tiny wrapper over coding in
evm directly
the third language is viper which is a
contract oriented programming language
influenced by python the fourth language
is serpent which is an assembly language
that compiles to evm code that is
extended with various high-level
features
the next language is mutant
mutant is similar to c like language and
supports a dynamic
full higher level language
it compiles to native ethereum assembler
however mutant is now deprecated
the last language is julia
it is an intermediate language that can
compile to various different backends
like evm 1.0 evm 1.5 and
ewasm
let me now tell you about the accounts
handled by ethereum
types of ethereum accounts
externally owned accounts eoa is an
account controlled by a private key that
has the ability to send ethers and
messages from it
following are some of the properties of
an externally owned account
firstly it has an ether balance
secondly it can send transactions
thirdly it is controlled by private keys
and fourthly it has no associated code
smart contract
smart contract is a code running on top
of the blockchain containing a set of
rules for the nodes to agree upon so
that they can interact with each other
as an account it has the following
properties
firstly it has an ether balance
secondly it has an associated code
thirdly a code execution is triggered by
transactions or messages received from
other contracts
and fourthly when executed it performs
operations of arbitrary complexity some
of the advantages of smart contracts are
as follows
first smart contract is the simplest way
of implementing decentralization
second it provides a high degree of
security
third it eliminates the need for a third
party
fourth it provides automatic agreement
enforcement
fifth it turns legal obligations into an
automated processes
and lastly it lowers the transaction
cost
characteristics of smart contracts
smart contracts are self-verifying and
self-executing
they operate autonomously to execute the
terms of the contract and verify the
transactions without the need of a third
party intervention
the elimination of third parties reduces
the cost of operations and further makes
the contracts tamper resistant
process of smart contracts
in this slide we will understand how the
smart contract works
first
an optional contract between the parties
is written as a code into the blockchain
the individuals involved are anonymous
but the contact is made through a public
ledger then a trigger event like an
expiration date or a strike price is hit
and the contract executes itself
according to the coded terms
next regulators can use the blockchain
to understand the activities in the
market while maintaining the privacy of
an individual's position let me show you
the implementation of smart contract in
a simple use case
smart contract example
here we have an example showing the
purchase and sale of a house thus once a
buyer is matched with a seller all
assets are sent into the contract
the contract then distributes the assets
based on certain predetermined
conditions agreed between both parties
and coded into the smart contract
thus the settlement is automated and the
ownership becomes undisputed due to the
transparency of blockchain
eoa versus smart contract
in this slide we will understand the
difference between an eoa and a smart
contract based on four critical
properties
nonce in an externally owned account
nonce represents the number of
transactions sent from the accounts
address
however in a contract account the nonce
is the number of contracts created by
the account
the next property is balance
this number shows the amount of way
owned by the address whether the eoa or
contract account
each ether is divided into 1e plus 18
wei the next property is code hash it is
the hash of the ethereum virtual machine
code of an account this is the code that
gets executed if this address receives a
message call it is immutable and thus it
cannot be changed once the construction
is done
for externally owned accounts the code
hash field is the hash of the empty
string
for contract accounts this is the code
that gets hashed and is stored as the
code hash the last property is storage
root it is a
256-bit hash of the root node of a
merkle tree that encodes the storage
contents of the account encoded into the
tree as a mapping from the keycap 256
bit hash of the 256 bit integer keys to
the rlp encoded 256 bit integer values
this tree encodes the hash of the
storage contents of this account and is
empty by default
that was all about the ethereum concepts
and accounts let's understand the
process of mining now
ethereum mining
ethereum mining
ethereum makes use of proof-of-work
mechanism to ensure security the
algorithm used in ethereum is called
ethash
each time an ethereum transaction is
made a miner is responsible for ensuring
the authenticity of information and
updating the blockchain with the
transaction
let's consider an example where bob
wants to send one eth to alice
now we will take a look at the
step-by-step process that is followed in
order to confirm this transaction
through mining
first bob attempts to send alice 1 eth
once bob's transaction is initiated it
is combined with other transactions that
have occurred in the last block
the miners will then validate the block
with a new set of instructions
once validated the miner creates a new
block and is rewarded for it
thus
alice receives one each after the
transaction is validated
ethereum mining
the term transaction is used in ethereum
to refer to the signed data package that
contains a message to be sent from an
eoa to another account on the blockchain
ethereum blocks contain two things a
transaction list and a recent state of
the ledger that comprises these
transactions
in the example shown on the screen we
can see a transaction where one wallet
sends 20 eth to another wallet the
diagram shows the previous state and the
next state for the transaction
state storage
the states are assembled into a state
tree that is linked to the account and
the block
the ethereum includes state routes that
store the root hash of the hash tree
which represents the system state when
the block was created now we will take a
look at the step-by-step process to see
how ethereum stores transactions
first a hash is generated for each
transaction
then pairs are selected and a hash is
generated for each pair
this way the last remaining hash becomes
the root
the block header as seen in the image on
the screen contains the previous block
hash and three merkle trees these trees
are to maintain the state
to maintain the transactions and to
maintain the receipts
also each block always refers to its
previous blocks hash
ethereum ecosystem
types of ethereum tools
the ethereum ecosystem consists of eight
major tools
they are
geth
ganache
parity
metamask
missed wallet
sporm
ipfs
whisper
now let's move forward and take a look
at each of these in detail
geth
geth is a multi-purpose command line
tool that runs an ethereum node
implemented in go
it is the official golang implementation
of the ethereum protocol and is commonly
used to interact with the ethereum
network
though there are several ways to
download geth the fastest one is to get
it from the ethereum.org website
next we have ganache cli
ganache cli
ganache cli is a customizable and fast
emulator for blockchain which permits
making calls to blockchain without the
need for running an actual ethereum node
following are some of the properties of
ganache
firstly transactions are mined instantly
secondly no transaction cost
thirdly accounts can be recycled reset
and instantiated with a fixed number of
ether without the need for faucets or
mining
fourthly gas price and mining speed can
be modified
fifthly a convenient gui gives you an
overview of your test chain events
parity
parity is the fastest lightest and most
secure
ethereum client that provides the core
infrastructure essentials for quick and
reliable services
parity is written in rust language it
offers better reliability code clarity
and performance
it is an ethereum client that is
integrated directly into your web
browser
apart from allowing the users to access
the functions of basic ether and token
wallet it also serves as an ethereum gui
browser
it provides access to a diverse range of
ethereum features including d apps
meta mask
metamask turns google chrome into a
browser that allows the users to send
and receive transactions and also fetch
data from the blockchain
it is a browser-based wallet which can
be added as a plug-in to your chrome
browser
it permits you to run ethereum d-apps
directly from your browser without the
need for running a full ethereum node
metamask accounts
practically it is unrealistic for
everyone in the world to run a node to
interact with the ethereum blockchain
to overcome this metamask hosts a number
of nodes so you don't have to
a user simply needs to install metamask
and can automatically get connected to
the nodes
thus you can use the ethereum blockchain
seamlessly
let's talk mist which is another
important tool of the blockchain
ecosystem
missed
wallet mist wallet is the end user
interface for ethereum that is developed
for browsing and using d apps
mist is an official ethereum wallet it
was developed and distributed by the
team which is responsible for the
management of ethereum ecosystem it is
usually used by developers who want to
create deploy and use smart contracts
it is a full node wallet which means
you'll have to download the entire
ethereum blockchain onto your computer
some of the applications of missed
wallet is as follows
first sending and receiving transactions
second
storing ether
third
creating multi-signature wallets
and fourth deploying smart contracts
swarm
swarm is a platform which supports
distributed storage and provides content
distribution services
it acts as a native base layer service
of the ethereum web 3 stack
it provides sufficient decentralization
and redundant storage of ethereum
records to distribute blockchain data as
well as the app codes
it leverages the underlying ethereum
infrastructure through the use of
contracts and ethers to encourage
cooperation among nodes
the files are split into pieces and are
stored in the nodes of the network an
accounting protocol is used by peers to
keep track of these chunks delivered and
received and resulting micropayments
associated with it
ipfs
ipfs is a decentralized storage system
that is not related directly to ethereum
but can be integrated with it
ipfs stores data by use of a distributed
hash table or dht
once we know the hash we request the
peer network who has a copy of the
content located at the corresponding
hash
and then we download the content from
the node who has the desired data which
we need
the data transfer between the nodes in
the network uses a mechanism which is
similar to the one used in bittorrent
it also provides a versioned file system
capable of storing files and tracking
versions over time
thus it defines how files move across a
network making it a distributed file
system by combining all of these
properties
ipfs is enabling a new permanent web and
augmenting the way we use existing
internet protocols like http
whisper
whisper is an identity based
communication protocol for d apps to
interact with each other d apps that
need to publish small amounts of
information to each other and have the
publication last some substantial amount
of time prefer using whisper
for instance
a d app running a currency exchange may
use whisper to record an offer to buy a
currency at a pre-agreed price on the
exchange platform
some of the drawbacks of whisper are as
follows it has low level api which is
only exposed to d apps and never to
users
second it has low bandwidth and is not
designed for large data transfers
third it has uncertain latency
and lastly it has no reliable methods
for tracing packets
ethereum frameworks
we'll look at two types of ethereum
frameworks
web3.js
web3.js
is a set of libraries which permit one
to interact with a remote or local
ethereum node
it can be done with the use of ipc or an
http connection the key connection
between ethereum network and dap that
allows you to compile deploy and
interact with smart contracts is called
web3.js
it gives us a way to build a website or
client that can talk to the ethereum
blockchain
let's take an example of traditional
development
when you develop a website it talks to
apis using json or jquery to make ajax
calls
a website talks to blockchain using web3
using
json.rpc which is similar to making a
remote procedure call
ethereum comprises of a large number of
nodes which talk to each other
we use jsonrpc
to make a request to a particular node
which is like an api call
thus if we want to talk to a smart
contract or read an account we do it
through web3
eth.js
it is a highly optimized lightweight js
utility for ethereum based on
web.js in this all the unnecessary
characters are removed from the source
code and the code is reduced to 160
kilobytes
ethereum development environment the
three commonly used ethereum development
environments include remix ide
truffle
and embark
let's understand these environments in a
little more detail
remix ide
remix ide is a browser-based compiler
and ide that enables users to debug
transactions and build ethereum
contracts with solidity language
you can simply log on to the web-based
editor write the code and compile the
same to create the byte code in order to
test your code the next slide shows how
remix looks
another popular environment is truffle
truffle
truffle is a development environment
testing framework and asset pipeline for
blockchains using the ethereum virtual
machine or evm
it helps users in developing smart
contracts
publish the contracts and test them
then we have embark
embark embark is an environment that
allows you to easily develop and deploy
decentralized applications
it performs the following functions
first automatic deployment of contracts
second keeping track of deployed
contracts
third managing the complex systems of
interdependent contracts
fourth performing test driven deployment
with contracts using javascript
fifth
managing different chains like testnet
private net and livenet and lastly
redeploy the contracts if any changes
are done
let's talk about ethereum networks
ethereum network
the basis for decentralized consensus is
the peer-to-peer network of
participating nodes which maintain and
secure the blockchain
a node is defined as a device or a
program that can communicate with the
ethereum blockchain network
they are also referred to as clients
they provide wallet functionality and
allow users to perform transactions on
the blockchain
thus a node serves as a machine running
as an ethereum client
it is used to store the data and
transfer money it is formed by combining
one or more nodes and each node contains
a copy of the blockchain
types of network there are three main
types of networks the test net the main
net and the private network
ethereum d-apps and daos
d-app
decentralized application is an
application that is used on networks
with trustless protocols to avoid a
single point of failure
they run on a peer-to-peer computer
network all the activity which takes
place on an ethereum decentralized
application
is cryptographically secured on the
blockchain
d-apps are open source which means that
everyone can verify the contents of the
software
some properties of d-apps are as follows
it uses ethereum as a development
platform
it uses cryptographically encoded blocks
it is not governed by a central server
and there is no master copy of the app
let's talk about the advantages of
d-apps now
advantages of d-app
ethereum d-apps have the following
advantages
improved stability due to a distributed
network
higher reliability
automatic credentials assigned through
smart contracts
no downtime
no third party intervention
and high security
example of dapps
some of the known examples of d-apps
include we fund
storage
kyc chain
and 4g capital these companies have
developed different applications using
blockchain
next we have the daos
dao
daos are organizations designed to hold
assets and use the voting system to
distribute them
they exist entirely on blockchain and
are governed by the consensus protocols
they show the potential of blockchain to
revolutionize human social institutions
called daos
it is an organization run by rules
agreed through a consensus process among
its members and written in a set of
contracts run via a blockchain
it is an open source software capable of
modification by its members
process of a dao
now let's take an example and see how
this works
let's consider that a country is holding
elections and wants to prevent fraud in
the voting system
a dao is created to keep transparency in
the voting
this is insured by embedding predefined
conditions in the code
people eligible to vote are assigned
voting tokens and the voting starts
every vote is processed on the ethereum
blockchain and it ensures transparency
by allowing everything to run in a
decentralized way in this video we will
explore ethereum mining and will go
through some of the fascinating concepts
and components revolving around it
first we will have an introduction to
ethereum
then we will understand what is ethereum
mining
then we will explore why should we mine
ethereum
we will look into the types of ethereum
mining
and then we will understand how the
ethereum mining process work
then we should explore how exactly to
mine ethereum
then we will discuss will the proof of
stake transaction kill proof of work
and then finally we will find out is
mining ethereum profitable
so without doing much ado let's get
started with the video
let's bring you up to speed on ethereum
ethereum is defined as a blockchain
based computing platform that enables
its developers to build and deploy
decentralized applications
and make sure all the transactions are
cryptographically secure in the network
ether is the cryptocurrency of material
used to build decentralized applications
smart contracts and make standard
peer-to-peer payments
ether basically acts as fuel for the
ethereum network it tracks and
facilitates all the transactions
so that brings us to what is ethereum
mining
in simple word ethereum mining is a
process of creating and adding a block
of transaction to the blockchain network
of ethereum it uses the proof-of-work
consensus mechanism for mining ethereum
all transactions taking place in the
ethereum network needs to get approved
by the miners
miners is a community of people using a
hashing script etas to solve
computationally hard puzzles for
successfully mining the blocks of
transactions in the ethereum blockchain
network
which helps secure the network from
attacks like hacking or manipulation of
identity
now let's understand why we need to mine
ethereum
the primary goal for mining ethereum is
to make money the data mining contract
of sectoring the network enter
relatively complex but profitable
business
also miners receive a certain amount as
a reward for mining each block of the
ethereum blockchain network
including the transaction fees paid by
the users
thus italian mining benefits each and
everyone participating in ethereum
blockchain network
so
what are the types of ethereum mining
ethereum mining can be performed in
three ways ethereum solo mining ethereum
coal mining and ethereum cloud mining
in ethereum solar mining you will get
rewarded only if you solve the puzzle
and mine dietary block first
since here you are competing with many
people and companies you have to be very
good at your work
also solo mining is only profitable when
you have plenty of resources with you
like 100 plus graphics cards
and in solo mining having so much
equipment may use a lot of electricity
and space leading to high electricity
bills and not everyone has a
considerable amount of air needed
italian pool mining is the easiest and
fastest way to get started with it area
mining
in this you work along with other people
together in a single pool
and if someone from the pool gets the
hash code correctly they share the
reward among everyone in the pool
we should consider a few important
factors before joining a pool life pool
size minimum payout and pool fee
pool size determines the number of
blocks you find in the ethereum network
and it shares the word
as the number of miners increases the
chances to get rewards also increase
minimum payout is the minimum amount of
ethereum you need to mine before it gets
credited to your wallet
and 40 is the amount you need to pay to
continue using the pool
this amount is percentage based on the
amount of ethereum you're mining
if here in cloud mining you pay someone
else with the equipment to my ethereum
for you
you pay some amount of money as peace to
them for investing their time and
resources
and in return they provide you with the
reward regained by the mining ethereum
but
this technique of mining ethereum has to
close and constantly
suppose you're not responsible for any
equipment damage you don't have to
require all the necessary equipment and
look for ample space to store it
you can sit back observe
market and enjoy the reward for your
investment interior mining
cons in the italian price drop then
there is no way you are getting your
money back the money you invested or the
fees paid to the miner is lost
and you can't ask the other person to
change the equipment according to your
concern
italian cloud mining is considered a
safer way for mining service providers
to guarantee a profit for the resource
they have purchased
now let's understand how the interior
mining process works
ethereum mining follows a specific set
of steps to function
step one a user requests a transaction
with the help of the private key of his
digital wallet account
then the request is shared worldwide
with the ethereum network
next the requested transaction is added
to a list of pending transactions that
needs to be added to the ethereum
blockchain network
step 4 the miner then verifies and
validates the requested transaction and
perform a complex mathematical puzzle on
the transaction data
step five once the request transaction
is verified
and it stores a copy of it in earlier
the process of proof of work begins for
the respective block
step six then the notes of the ethereum
network verify for the checksum of the
state of the miners block matches the
checksum of the updated state of the
union after execution of all
transactions
step 7 only after that the block is
added to the ethereum blockchain network
step 8 on successfully mining the block
it rewards the miner with some amount of
ether in their wallet
the block reward of ethereum is three
ether
and step nine the requested transaction
is approved and credited for the
respective wallet or wallet
each transaction is mined only once with
every participant of the ethereum
network verifies it
this makes me curious about how to mine
ethereum
tools you will need to be an efficient
miner for ethereum on your personal
computer are
a wallet to store all your currency on
gpu drivers or graphics card with a
minimum of 3gb ram
a mining software suitable according to
your hardware like gpu
and a compatible operating system
windows 7 or 10 with 64 bit
before getting started with mining
iteration you need to create an ethereum
wallet to store all your ether
press model t and ledger nano are the
most reliable and secure wallets in the
market of cryptocurrency
installing gpu drivers or graphics card
after creating your digital wallet
you'll need to update all the hardware
that is drives in your system
you can use two types of graphics card
they are amd graphics card and nvidia
graphics card
claymore is considered the best
processor mining ethereum on gp drivers
now we need to follow a few
set of steps to get started with mining
step 1 download the latest version of
claymore dual miner for the operating
system
the latest version is claymore 11.0
step 2 click on the latest version of
windows and download the zip file
step 3. extract the file with claymore
11.0 to a folder on desktop for easy
access
open the folder to have a look at the
files
step 5. right click on start and then on
the edit option
step 6. edit the start.txt file and add
these lines
step seven choose your desired pool from
these recommendations
you can also find better search results
than these according to your region
step eight type in your pool address
instead of mining pool address
step 9 save your start.txt file within
new updates
remember while saving select type as all
files
and step 10 once you save click on the
clay.that file to begin mining ethereum
now let's explore will the proof of
state transition field trooper work
newly introduced concept of ethereum 2.0
roadmap plans to upgrade to proof of
stake
consensus algorithm in which it will
provide all existing miners of the dairy
network with a limited time to earn a
return for the investment
this expected to be launched by the end
of 2021
or the starting of 2022
it was supposed to be launched by
october 2020 but the history of delays
regarding this update
is worth talking about
nobody truly knows when ethereum 2.0
will be completed and introduced to the
crypto mining world
now we may know all about ethereum my
name this makes me wonder if eternal
mining is profitable
the profit of any crypto mining majorly
depends on the cost of electricity in
that particular area
as a rule anything below 0.12
per kilowatt consumes in an hour is
considered profitable you can mine ether
and turn it into a vital source of
income by analyzing these figures like
hash rate of ethereum block reward
number of blocks per day and the coin
price of ethereum
you can also use an iterating calculator
to figure out the daily revenue basing
it on these factors
or you can use this formula too
the predictions are made that the
ethereum price can rise and become more
stable in the coming few years so it is
an excellent opportunity to invest in
and save an ethereum
in this video we will explore ethereum
2.0 and will go through some of the
fascinating concepts and components
revolving around it
so what is the ethereum network
ethereum is defined as a blockchain
based computing platform that enables
its developers to build and deploy
decentralized application
either in the cryptocurrency for
ethereum used to build decentralized
application smart contracts and make
standard peer-to-peer payments
it tracks and facilitates all the
transactions and make sure they are
cryptographically secure in the network
ether basically acts as a fuel for the
ethereum network
so what is ethereum 2.0
ethereum 2.0 is a set of interrelated
upgrades that will make the ethereum
network more secure scalable and
sustainable
multiple teams from across the ethereum
ecosystem have come together to work on
these upgrades in ethereum 2.0
then what led to the region of ethereum
2.0
with growing popularity ether and the
ethereum network has gotten more blocked
by transactions
currently it is capable of handling 15
to 45 transactions per second
which is comparatively impressive but it
is not enough to handle all of italian's
users worldwide
also the high demand is affecting the
driving up of transaction fees
nodes power the ethereum blockchain
network but currently its nodes are
experiencing too much volume
although the programmers working on the
upgrade have claimed that making its
nodes bigger wouldn't be practical
ethereum 2.0 intends to make the network
more scalable to handle all of the
activities on the ethereum network
that makes us wonder what are the
changes in ethereum 2.0
the two significant changes that will
come with the upgrade are adopting proof
of state and sharding
adopting proof of stake ethereum
blockchain implementations suffer from
performance issues because they rely on
a processing power intensive process
known as proof of work to record and
validate their transactions
the problem with proof of works design
is that it's very inefficient
ethereum 2.0 will solve these issues by
transitioning its blockchain to a more
efficient proof-of-stake system
it will decrease the complexities faced
by the network leading to massive
throughput gains for the whole network
sharding is a process that intends to
enhance ethereum's efficiency and
ability to scale
in the current version of ethereum
blockchain all data that is added to the
chain undergoes verification by all
participating nodes
that means that the speed of its fluids
participant limits the processing speed
of the entire network
sharding will increase the efficiency of
the network resources by breaking data
verification tasks among its set of
nodes
and each of them will be responsible for
validating and verifying just the data
allotted to them
this will increase the network's overall
capacity and make it much faster and
efficient
than its outdated version
so what is the current status of
ethereum 2.0 research
why ethereum 2.2 has been in research
and development since 2014.
it has actually been making some
progress
the beacon chain went live in december
2020 introducing the staging concept
but still there is no official claim for
the completion of this transition
the next phase is mainet
merging the beacon chain into the
current ethereum network
mining ethereum tokens will officially
end in this phase and staking will
become the primary way to create new
tokens in the ethereum network
the last part of the transition is
expected to unfold in multiple phases
like adding the shard genes to give the
ethereum blockchain network more
capacity and efficiency to handle all of
the demand and increased transactions
per second
although it has been a long road and
there is still a good deal of
uncertainty around the timing the
ethereum developers do seem to be
motivated and on their way to completing
the whole transition so what is the
future of ethereum 2.0
if executed properly this transition to
ethereum 2.0 could be a total game
changer it will create a modified
network that could potentially process
one lag transactions per second
and a much more sustainable network
without the energy intensive mining
process and it will introduce smart
contracts worldwide
increasing the ethereum's network
utility
furthermore ethereum co-founder with
alex buterin once said that the issuance
of new token should be highly reduced
under ethereum 2.0 which could increase
its demand
given all these factors ethereum 2.0
seems to hold a bright future for
ethereum blockchain network in the
previous videos we covered what bitcoin
and ethereum are let's proceed further
and have a look at how they both differ
from each other did you know there are
more than 1600 cryptocurrencies
worldwide
and among them bitcoin and ethereum have
always been the top two most popular
cryptocurrencies in the world by market
cap
also recently ethereum as well as
bitcoin reached its all-time peak in
worldwide trading
according to decrypt.gov everyday new
companies like metoo and paypal are
coming forward to invest in bitcoin and
ethereum
on march 7 2021 mitu confirmed that it
had purchased 40 million in bitcoin and
ethereum on the other hand people is
about to launch a scheme where the
public can purchase and sell
cryptocurrencies initially featuring
bitcoin and ethereum via paypal digital
wallet
but have you all ever wondered how they
compare based on their similarities and
differences in various aspects
well before moving any further let's
have a quick look at how bitcoin and
ethereum originated and made a benchmark
in the economic system worldwide
bitcoin was first introduced in 2009 by
satoshi nakamoto to resolve cyber
attacks double spending and eliminate
the middleman between the transaction
it led the first revolution of digital
money which enables transparent and
decentralized peer-to-peer transaction
on the other hand ethereum came into the
picture years after bitcoin it was first
introduced in the late 2013 by vitalik
buterin after that it was very quickly
and widely adopted because it offered a
platform to build and run applications
without any downtime fraud or
interference of any third party
ethereum serves as a computing platform
that enables its developers to build and
deploy their decentralized application
now let's move ahead and see the
difference between them which make them
compete with each other in this economy
this video will cover individual aspects
for comparing ethereum and bitcoin's
performance in that particular field
first we will look into the introduction
of ethereum and bitcoin
then the algorithm they follow
the programming language
mining process of ethereum and bitcoin
monetary policy
transaction
and availability of these two
cryptocurrencies
by time bitcoin has proved itself as a
well-known cryptocurrency however
ethereum with different functionalities
is giving a quite tough competition to
bitcoin but before moving ahead let's
have an introduction to ethereum and
bitcoin
ethereum is a platform that builds
immutable smart contracts an application
for its users without any centralized
interference for bitcoin it is an
alternative to fiat money or physical
currency the main function of ethereum
is to provide its users or developers
with a platform to build smart contracts
using dapps or decentralized application
on the other side bitcoin only intends
to be a medium of exchange of money and
value stored in its blockchain network
now let's get started and move towards
the first comparison which is algorithm
ethereum uses the etas cryptographic
algorithm for mining blocks in the
ethereum network on the other hand
bitcoin uses the she-256 hashing
algorithm for mining blocks in the
bitcoin network
ethers algorithm is mainly used during
the proof of work function
proof of work is a small piece of data
that is difficult to generate but easy
to validate and satisfy certain network
requirements
sag 256 algorithm helps bitcoin users to
protect all their sensitive data like
private keys moving on the programming
language of ethereum
and bitcoin
ethereum uses solidity solidity is a
high level programming language used by
ethereum for implementing smart
contracts but in terms of programming
language bitcoin keeps it simple bitcoin
uses c
as its programming language it is a
stack based programming language used to
give bitcoin software instructions on
how to make transactions
as we have covered the algorithm and
programming language of both
cryptocurrencies now let's take a look
at the mining process of both
mining is a process in which transaction
made are validated and added to
blockchain public ledger and blocks and
the people mining these blocks are
called miners
ethereum miners mine the unvalidated
transaction using the proof
proof-of-work method but it aims to
switch to proof of stake because it will
make its network more immune to
centralization energy efficient and
stronger support for the shared chain
on the other hand similar to ethereum
bitcoin miners also use the
proof-of-work method to mine unvalidated
transactions
these method is enough to function in
bitcoin network worldwide now let's
proceed towards the monetary policy of
both cryptocurrencies but let's first
understand what monetary policy is
monetary policy is known as the process
of drafting announcing and implementing
the plan of actions taken by the
competent monetary authority to control
the money supply and achieve goals that
promote sustainable economic growth so
italian's policy is defined by the
reward paid out by its protocol
ethereum's monetary policies are best
described as minimum issuance to secure
the network therefore there is a
constant trade-off between the
transaction speed and security but
bitcoin's monetary policy comprises two
parts halving and block frequency
halving event is when the reward of
mining bitcoin is cut in half and it
also cuts the inflation rate and the
block reward is the number of bitcoins
you get if you successfully mine a
blockchain block the current block
reward for ethereum is two ether per
block and for bitcoin
the block reward is 12.5 bitcoins per
block
also every 14 seconds a block of
ethereum is generated and one block of
bitcoin takes 10 minutes to generate
monetary policies are considered to be
fixed and non-inflationary due to this
over time mining blocks will become more
difficult next is transactions
ethereum is a little bit faster than
bitcoin with 30 transactions per second
and it takes just a few minutes to
confirm it on the other side bitcoin's
transaction speed is 5 transactions per
second and it can take up to 60 minutes
or more to confirm either the currency
of ethereum acts as the fuel for
ethereum networks and bitcoin is only
used as the value for real-world
transaction to compete with already
present electronic cash like credit
cards and google pay it error and
bitcoin require higher productivity to
attain widespread adoption not talking
about the availability of both
cryptocurrencies
ethereum is not limited but it can
occasionally reduce due to large network
upgrades however bitcoin is limited to
21 million coins and as of today 18
million bitcoin is already used
but in the end both bitcoin and ethereum
being the top crypto currencies share a
few similarities like both are
decentralized and can be used to have a
peer-to-peer transaction
proof of work also both have a large
network of independent nodes now let's
have a demo now let's have a look at the
media outlet website coindesk where we
will see all stats related to bitcoin
and ethereum in detail
coindesk is a site specialized in
digital currencies it is used to explore
the news and price data related to
cryptocurrencies and also explains how
cryptocurrencies contribute to the
evolution of financial system worldwide
now see this graph this graph shows the
change in bitcoin price in 24 hours
duration
this graph shows the gradual change in
the price of bitcoin it started from 64
439.29 on april 14 at 12 pm
and right now by april 15 at 6 00 am it
is at 63 189
the rate of change is minus 0.46 percent
which shows the change in the price of
bitcoin per hour
let's have a look at this graph of
ethereum 2.
the value
of ethereum started at 2
388.13
on april 14 at 12 p.m and the current
status on april 15 is positive with a
value of two thousand four hundred forty
two point three seven dollars with an
increasing rate of four point six seven
percent down below we have a metrics
table that shows the change between the
starting and ending value of ethereum
the total supply of a cryptocurrency in
24 hours the total number of transaction
that occurred and the average
transaction fee for all these
transactions now this graph shows the
current status of cryptocurrency in usd
dollars we can also see its value
according to any centralized currency
like euro or inr this graph shows the
concentrating change in the value of
cryptocurrencies every moment we can
also access the data of trading from an
hour to its lifetime recently we all
have been hearing about a cryptocurrency
famously known as dogecoin but what
exactly makes it so different from
others that almost every person is
talking about it
so let me tell you that dogecoin is an
altcoin and an almost sarcastic meme
coin that serves as a peer-to-peer
open-source cryptocurrency
well that's not enough so let's dive
down and understand the concept of
dogecoin more precisely but before
starting let's have a look at why is it
in the news since the beginning of the
year 2021 dogecoin has surged more than
950 percent from less than half a penny
to more than five cents per dogecoin
then elon musk ceo of tesline
corporation took his interest in it and
tweeted too much concentration is the
only real issue but cryptocurrency
making the owner of the dogecoin wallet
a subject of attention later on at the
same of 10 billion dollars in this video
we will come across the following topics
first we will see the origin of dogecoin
and then we will understand what is
dogecoin how does it exactly works
and then we will see what led to the
growth of dogecoin
what are the areas of uses of dogecoin
then we will figure out what is the
current value of those coin today
and lastly how can we buy it
let's start with the origin of dogecoin
dogecoin was invented by two software
engineers ibm engineer billy marcus and
adobe engineer jackson palmer did you
know that they never even met before
combining the two most significant
phenomena of the year 2013 bitcoin and
deutsche well now let's move ahead and
see what is dogecoin dogecoin is a
peer-to-peer open source cryptocurrency
that provides its user a completely
unknown decentralized and secure
environment free from any third-party
interference to make their transaction
dodge coin was intended to be an altcoin
and a meme coin inspired by shiba inu's
popular meme aka doj moving ahead let's
have a look at how it works to
understand the workflow let's take the
example of two friends mark and susan
mark owes some money to susan and now he
needs to return it
so he thinks of an idea and decides to
send her dogecoin instead of giving her
physical money
they both open their digital wallet
account
to pay her he needs two essential pieces
of information
first his private key
and second her public key
to get access to susan's private key he
needs to scan a qr code from his
smartphone then the application alerts
all the dogecoin miners around the world
to proceed further with the process the
dojo and miners validate whether mark
has enough dogecoin to make the payment
or not
and after the validation process they
approve the transaction request dogecoin
miners race with each other to collect
all the data of the pending transaction
known as the nonce
the miners then apply a mathematical
function to produce the correct hash
number for the particular nonce of the
pending transaction the miner who
successfully produces the correct hash
number is rewarded with 25 dogecoin in
his account
after that mark and susan gets a
confirmation message that they request
for the transaction has been approved
and within 10 minutes the requested
amount of dogecoin is credited into the
wallet of susan
thus the transaction is completed
so what led to the growth of dogecoin
dogecoin officially came live in 2013
and became an instant hit within the
community of people who just wanted to
play around the cryptocurrencies freely
as i said earlier dogecoin was intended
to be a joke for content creators but
they were very well received it uses of
internet forums like reddit and twitter
adopted dogecoin and started tipping
their content creators this usage of
dogecoin made it surpass the trading
value of the other cryptocurrencies
specifically bitcoin in 2014.
it also started doing charity work to
introduce and promote themselves in the
real world for example once they raise a
fund of 55 000 for a nascar driver josh
weiss and in return he printed the logo
and 98 dogecoin over this race car
eventually it almost became the mascot
for what crypto should be
let's have a look at who uses dogecoin
today many companies and firms like
restaurants process
web hosting
products retailer
ebook sellers and travel services uses
dogecoin for transaction
these are a few examples
of companies in every sector that uses
dogecoin
grossers hellopets gamerheats.com for
web hosting
gamer
for products retailer meltdown and
noddex
ebook seller canal
and travel services like bello leo dot
id this makes me curious about the
current value of dogecoin let's have a
look at that too
according to the market cap today the
current value of dogecoin is 0.059357
usd with a trading volume of 16 billion
dollars the circulating supply of this
cryptocurrency is 129 billion dogecoins
and the max supply of dogecoin is not
available
how can we buy dogecoin
so to buy dogecoin we will have to
follow a few steps step 1 open a digital
wallet buy you coin is considered a
perfect application for trading
cryptocurrencies step 2 register your
account
step 3 complete your profile kyc by
providing your identity and address
proof like aadhar step 4 add your bank
account details
step 5 secure your account by creating a
convenient trading pin that is only
accessible by you
and step six
there you go now you can start trading
that is all about dogecoin currently we
have heard a lot of buzz about the
cryptocurrency dogecoin and the
shenanigans of its community
did you know that on 20th april 2020
dogecoin searched its value to one
dollar
making this day named after itself as
day
the supporters of dogecoin were trying
to amplify the value of it to make it
one dollar
but how is it done in reality how can we
affect the value and availability of
cryptocurrency
well all this is done by a process
called mining
and this is what affected torch coin
resulting in the rise of its value
mining coins of the deutsche coin
network is called dogecoin mining
now let's move ahead and see what's in
this video for you
first we will have an introduction to
what is dogecoin
then we will figure out the net worth of
dogecoin today
we will understand what dogecoin mining
is
then we will have a comparison of mining
process of dogepoint with a few other
cryptocurrencies like bitcoin
then we will dive into how to mine
deutsche coin
in this segment first we will see types
of dogecoin mining like pool and solo
then we will see what exactly you
require to start dogecoin mining
what hardware and software you need for
dogecoin mining
and then we will understand a new
concept of deutsche coin mining which is
dogecoin cloud mining
and in the end we will analyze whether
dogecoin mining is profitable or not
so let's get started and have a quick
look at what is tote coin
dogecoin is a peer-to-peer open source
cryptocurrency that works on blockchain
technology
also it provides its users a completely
unknown decentralized and secure
environment free from any third-party
interference to make their transactions
dosh going to use the skiptography to
secure all its transactions
this makes me curious to know what is
the net worth and availability of those
going today
according to market cap today the
current value of dogecoin is
0.266247 usd dollars the circulating
supply of this cryptocurrency is 127
billion dogecoin
so that brings us to what is dodecoin
mining dogecoin mining is a process of
validating the data blocks of
transactions by solving a complex
mathematical problem and adding them to
the dogecoin network
each confirmation of transactions adds a
new block to the dogecoin network
miners perform this process those point
miners are a community of people who
perform complex mathematical solutions
on the transactions for mining dogecoin
that makes me wonder what the difference
between dogecoin mining and other
cryptocurrencies mining process
let's have a comparison between dogecoin
mining and the bitcoin mining process
we will be comparing these crypto mining
based on these factors
first
algorithm
it is a set of rules that every
cryptocurrency follows for mining new
coins
in the algorithm doj coin mining uses
script bitcoin mining uses she-256
script is considered a lot quicker and
cheaper than the ssg256 algorithm making
mining easier for miners of the dogecoin
network
second is difficulty
this represents the complexities and
challenges faced by miners to mine each
block of the blockchain of any
cryptocurrency
in difficulty dogecoin is 2 798
2252
bitcoin is three trillion five hundred
eleven billion sixty million
five hundred fifty two thousand eight
hundred ninety nine thus it proves that
dodge coin is easier to mine among other
cryptocurrencies
third is block time
it is the time taken by a new block of
transactions to be checked confirmed and
added to the blockchain block time of
dogecoin is one minute for bitcoin it is
10 minutes
and at fourth and fifth we have reward
per block and per block usd
it is the amount
in usd to the miner for each block added
to the network
block reward for dogecoin is 10 000
dogecoins per block which in usd is
27.36 dodge coins
for bitcoin it is 12.5 bitcoin per block
and in usd it is 86
391.63 bitcoins
moving on finally we have reached the
most crucial point of this video now we
will have a look at how to mine dogecoin
dogecoin can be mined in two ways the
first one
dogecoin pool mining and the second is
solo mining
a dogecoin pool is a group of people who
share their computing power to mine
dogecoin transaction data and get
rewarded by equal share after confirming
the transaction
solo mining is when only one person does
all the work of mining and confirming
transactions
the reward is awarded only to that
person after confirming the transaction
let's have a thorough discussion of the
difference between dogecoin pool mining
and solo my name
in dogecoin pool mining you have to mine
as a part of it and pay fees
in dojo in solo mining you don't need to
pay any fees and your mine all by
yourself
also in pole mining you will only get a
part of the reward earned by the pool
one button solo mining the total reward
on will be received by you only
as in pool mining many people work
together so the mind blocks more often
and on the other side solo mining could
take a lot of time before one mine the
first block
in pool mining it takes less time to
confirm a transaction as you work as a
part of the pool community on the other
hand in solo mining it can take much
longer to confirm a transaction as you
do all the work and there is a lot of
competition
so this was all about dogecoin pool
mining and solar mining
let's proceed further and see what we
need to start mining dogecoin
before we start mining we will have to
make sure that we have these things with
us a pc with any operating system like
windows linux ubuntu etc
a good internet connection
and a digital wallet to store the
dogecoins you mine which hardware and
software can we use for dogecoin mining
you will need your pc cpu which should
be powerful enough to mine dogecoin a
gpu a graphics card can also be used for
mining dogecoin for example sapphire
pulse radeon rx 580 asus rx vega 64 and
many more
stripped asic miner is programmed to
mine script-based cryptocurrencies like
dogecoin
like
bitmain antminer l3 bwl 21 strip miner
etc
if you are new to dogecoin mining then
using your pc cpu will be the right
choice and cpu miner is the most
appropriate software
if you are thinking of mining using gpu
or graphics card you can have a wide
range of software
some of the best software is buddha
miner which works perfectly with
nvidia products cgminer which works with
most gpu hardware and easy miner is
considered suitable for beginners script
asic miners are considered to be very
powerful hardware and multi miner is
excellent with this hardware moving
ahead let's understand what does coin
cloud mining is
doscoin cloud mining is a mechanism to
mine dogecoin using rented data centers
without installing any hardware and
related softwares
it allows people to take an interest and
participate in deutsche point mining at
a very low cost making dogecoin mining
accessible for a broader range of people
worldwide
since the deutsche coin mining process
uses the cloud it reduces equipment
maintenance or direct energy cost
this whole concept of dogecoin mining
brings me in front of one question
is dotecoin mining profitable
dogecoin mining profitability can be
analyzed based on power consumption hash
rate and cost
the dogecoin mining calculator is used
to make it simple in this calculator
the default value for the latest
dogecoin mining hash rate and latest
dogecoin difficulty target is pre-loaded
for better results
dogecoin mining's reward is
forty four lakh forty four thousand four
hundred twelve point two five dollars
per year that is
fourteen million doge per year the block
time for dogecoin is one minute which
means the supply of dogecoin will never
go down
after deducting mining power costs and
mining fees the final daily dogecoin
mining profit is
22.53 torch coin to usd with a profit
margin of
positive
81.72 percent
also i think dogecoin mining is fun
so that is all about dogecoin mining
we covered what dogecoin is
its value today and understood dogecoin
mining and its concepts in the previous
two videos
now let's proceed further and look at
how to create a doj point wallet and how
to use it let's get started what is
torch point
dogecoin is a peer-to-peer open-source
cryptocurrency that works on a
blockchain technology also it provides
its users a completely unknown
decentralized and secure environment
free from any third-party interference
to make their transactions torch coin
uses cryptography to secure all its
transactions now let's proceed further
and have a look at the process of how to
buy dogecoin
you can buy dogecoin by following these
steps step one create a dot coin wallet
step two locate your specific dogecoin
address which is a long area of
characters that starts from capital d
followed by any other capital character
or any number
and step three find the source that
sells dogecoin
and voila buy dodge coins so that brings
us to what is dogecoin wallet
a dojo wallet is something where you can
stop store receive or send dogecoins
technically it is very similar to a real
live wallet
dogecoin wallet consists of its public
and private key connecting it to the
distributed ledger over the dogecoin
network
you can use your wallet's public key
which also functions as your coin
address for your bank account number for
dogecoin where anyone can track the
transactions made by maintaining the
anonymity of the user
the private key of your wallet is used
to approve transactions in the ledger
your wallet's public key is used to
receive doj coins from other users on
the other hand your wallet's private key
is only used to send torch points to
other users in the network so what are
the types of dogecoin wallet
deutsche and wallet is of two types
digital dodge coin wallet
and physical dodge point wallet digital
dodge coin wallet is accessible through
the web and you can also download it
according to your handset or operating
system
on the other hand physical dojo and
wallets are pretty expensive and less
accessible
so moving on let's see how to create a
dogecoin wallet
to create a doj coin wallet for yourself
you will have to go through the
following steps
step 1 choose the correct wallet dot
coin core wallet and multi-touch wallet
have been created and are maintained by
the developers team of dogecoin
here we will be using the dojo and core
wallet as reference
step 2 download and install the dogecoin
wallet in your handset
you can also use the official website of
this wallet for your windows
and step 3 open the dogecoin wallet
application and verify your dogecoin
wallet address
and that is it it is this easy to create
and have your dogecoin wallet now when
you have your dutch coin wallet in your
hand let's see how you can use it on the
very bottom of the home page of your
wallet there are two options
request coins where you can request
torch coins from other users in the
dogecoin network
and send coins where you can send
dogecoins to other users in the dogecoin
network to receive coins first click on
the request coins button
second enter the required number of
coins you want to request
and third
have the below generated barcode scanned
by the user you wish to request the
mount
now to send coins
first type the dodge coin wallet address
to whom you want to send dogecoins
enter the required amount you wish to
send to that user
and third click on send
and there you go now you can use your
dotecoin wallet whenever and wherever
you want this makes me wonder why is
dogecoin so popular
despite being in tough competition with
other strong cryptocurrencies like
bitcoin dogecoin has never missed an
opportunity to be in the limelight
dogecoin's popularity is mainly
attributed to its vast and dedicated
community
other than that social platforms like
reddit and twitter also promoted
dogecoin to a great extent due to its
fun factor and the whole joke story
behind it
celebrities like snoop dogg kevin jonas
elon musk also started taking an
interest in dogepoint and posting
pictures and comments on their social
media handles which increased the craze
of dogecoin all around the world so this
was all about dogecoin wallet now let's
have a look at the top 5 deutsche point
wallets of 2021
these are the top 5 dogecoin wallets of
2021
ledger nano x treasure model t
kepke binance and kraken
kraken is primarily a cryptocurrency
exchange platform but can perfectly act
as a dogecoin wallet
all you need to do is to register and
then buy some dogecoins
it is a very secure and reliable
cryptocurrency exchange platform
it charges a very low fees for every
transaction taking place on it
and it accepts a pretty decent amount of
fiat money what comes to your mind first
when you hear the word dogecoin
i'm pretty sure either it's a meme or
elon musk
well whatever we think of this
cryptocurrency we can't deny the fact
that dogecoin started as a joke not
turned into the crypto star of the
future
everyone one or the other way knows
about dogecoin
but do you know what makes it so unique
and popular in this video i will take
you through some amazing top 10 facts
about dogecoin
so let's get started
number one
dogecoin has several safety levels
security levels are partially based on
the number of nodes of cryptocurrency
dogecoin has 1090 nodes which makes it
irresistible to hacking plus sometimes
the traffic increases in the dogecoin
network making it more vulnerable to its
security
number two huge and interactive
community of followers
among all of the cryptocurrencies those
coin today has the biggest community of
followers they genuinely believe that
dogecoin will rule the future
and this unity proved to be an advantage
for dogecoin
for instance
once china banned all the payment
companies dealing with bitcoin
which led to the increase of deutsche
and reddit users up to 19 000 in just
two weeks thus the price of dogecoin
escalated to 300 percent
those coins followed provide full
support
to dogecoin and acting unity to try
every bit to make it more popular and
grow
once they raised a fund of 55 000
dollars for a nascar driver john weiss
who in return covered his entire car
with dogecoin and reddit alien images
such a beautiful family
number three
dogecoin is the easiest to buy
the platform for cryptocurrency exchange
provides the most convenient ways to buy
dogecoin
all you need is to create a digital
wallet which can be done on any
cryptocurrency exchange platform's
official website
and choose a reliable exchanger like
kraken or coinbase
and you will also need some bitcoins to
exchange it with doge
that's it it is this simple to trade
dogecoin now you can get rolling with
buying dogecoin
number four
dogecoin wallet inspired by lucky coin
dogecoin was based on lucky coin as both
of them used the script language
to make dogecoin more ridiculous palmer
and marcus added a weird feature to the
dogecoin wallet
stating that its miner could receive
either 0
or potentially thousands of free coins
to produce new blocks inspired by one of
the quirky features of lucky coin
after a while they changed the block
reward to a fixed number of ten thousand
to make it more feasible
well i think dogecoin needs to be a
little different from these
cryptocurrencies as it holds a different
history of original growth
to maintain the faith of its community
it needs to upgrade itself a bit
number five
largest circulating supply of the coin
dogecoin in the crypto market holds the
position of the largest circulating
supply of coins
since both the founders of dogecoin
wanted it to be a ridiculous joe they
thought of generating as many dogecoin
unit as possible
therefore they ended up making a
circulating supply of 127 million
dogecoin which is relatedly higher than
the volume of other cryptocurrencies
like bitcoin or ethereum
till today almost 113 billion dolce
coins are already mine
every day
10 000 new dogecoins are released in
block rewards
every minute roughly 14.4 million new
dogecoins entering into the circulation
every day therefore 5.2 billion
dogecoins per year
dogecoin mining process is one of the
fastest
at least 98.9815
dogecoin can be mined every day dogecoin
uses script encryption which cannot be
harvested using asics making it easier
and faster to mine other than
cryptocurrencies like bitcoin
also the block rate is one block per
minute this provides an excellent
opportunity for miners to mine more
blocks and earn as many block rewards as
possible and miner can make make at
least 10 000 dogecoins as a block reward
number seven market capitalization over
435 million dollar
when dogecoin was first introduced to
the crypto world it was supposed to be
taken as a joke
but the people very well received it
this led its more value than 435 million
by 2017
i don't know about others but this value
of money is a lot
imagine if you had invested 1000 on
torch coin in january 2017 and then sold
it all after a month
do you know how much money you would
have earned
almost twenty two thousand dollars
today the market cap worth of dogecoin
is 70 billion dollars
making it the fourth most valued coin
number eight huge fan following in the
entertainment world
dogecoin seems to have gained a lot of
popularity among celebrities like snoop
dogg
kevin jonas gene simmons and elon musk
recently kevin jonas the eldest jonas
brother posted saying all i was saying
doge
showing his interest in dogecoin gene
simmons from the classic rock band kiss
also made a massive revelation that he
owns six figures worth of dogecoin well
some have been posting funny pictures or
comments to promote this crypto over
social media and some have been trying
to change the perception of people for
dogecoin
number nine
widely represented on social media
dogecoin has been widely represented on
social media since its origin platforms
like reddit and twitter adopted dogecoin
in its initial days and started
promoting it by tipping dogecoin to
their content creators which turned out
to be a massive success for dogecoin
dojkun began to catch the attention of
every user on these platforms
i feel twitter has been a slam book for
torch coin as every day one or the other
person tweets about dogecoin there
later other platforms like tick tock
also started developing their interest
in dogecoin in summer 2020 tick tock
introduced a dogecoin challenge to
encourage people to invest in dogecoin
number 10 elon musk the flag bearer of
dogecoin
when deutsche is mentioned how can we
not talk about tesla ceo elon musk
but the question is what makes him love
dogecoin so much
recently one of his followers tweeted
and asked him why do you love dot so
much
he reacted that he loves dogs
and loves memes
he has been so active with dogecoin by
constantly tweeting about it
his first tweet was torched to the moon
which grabbed the attention of both the
followers of elon and followers of
dogecoin
this led to the overnight increase in
the price and popularity of dogecoin
later he posted a still from lion king
movie which with his face in place of
rafiki holding simba with the face of
dogecoin stating that he will always
have dogecoins back
his most recent tweet was on wednesday
may 5 2021 the dogecoin father snl may 8
which is a reference to both his
constant tweets on dogecoin as well as
his appearance on saturday night live on
may 8 2020. in the previous few videos
we learned about what dogecoin is and he
also had a comparison between ethereum
and bitcoin in which we talked about
their features and concepts behind the
mechanism
but in this video we will compare and
contrast dogecoin bitcoin and ethereum
based on a few related concepts around
these cryptocurrencies
it will help us understand the
functioning of these top
cryptocurrencies and will also let us
figure out the individuality of each one
of them
dogecoin was intended to be an altcoin
and a meme coin inspired by shiba inu's
popular meme aka doj
but it was very well received by
everyone in the crypto world and today
it is the fourth top cryptocurrency
dogecoin is a peer-to-peer open-source
cryptocurrency that provides its users
with a completely unknown decentralized
and secure environment to make their
transactions
bitcoin led the first revolution of
digital money in 2013.
bitcoin enables transparent and
decentralized peer-to-peer transaction
bitcoin is designed to be an alternative
to national currencies and intends only
to be a medium of exchange and value
storage
it comprises of features like a public
ledger immutability and high
transparency making it a great platform
ethereum came into the picture years
after bitcoin ethereum offered a
platform to build and run applications
without any downtime fraud or
interference of any third party
ethereum serves as a computing platform
that enables its developers to build and
deploy their decentralized applications
using smart contracts through its
currency ether or eth
the primary function of ether is to help
developers build smart contracts using
dapps or decentralized application
now let's move on the comparison between
dogecoin bitcoin and ethereum
we will be comparing them based on few
major parameters like algorithm
programming language mining process
monetary policies
transactions
today's value
and availability
so let's move ahead and start with the
very first comparison the algorithm
dogecoin uses stripped cryptography for
mining the blocks of the dogecoin
network
in comparison bitcoin uses the sha-256
hashing algorithm for mining its blocks
in the blockchain network
ethereum on the other hand uses the e
dash algorithm for mining its
transactions
script language is a password-based key
derivation function that is mainly used
to avoid customized hardware attacks by
raising the resource demands of the
algorithm
she 256 algorithm helps bitcoin users
protect all their sensitive data like
private keys or transaction details and
help maintain the anonymity of the user
for a much secure performance of
transactions
e-algorithm is mainly used during the
proof-of-work function proof-of-work is
a small piece of data that is difficult
to generate but easy to validate and
satisfy specific network requirements
moving on the following comparison
programming language
dogecoin is considered to be an all coin
for bitcoin vote dogecoin and bitcoin
use the same programming language
c plus it is a stack based programming
language used to give bitcoin and
dogecoin software instructions on how to
make transactions
on the other side ethereum uses solidity
which is a high level programming
language used by ethereum for
implementing smart contracts
now that we have covered programming
language and the algorithm of this
cryptocurrency
let's get to the following very
important parameter which is mining
process
but before getting started with the
comparison first let's understand what
mining is
mining is a process in which
transactions are validated and added to
the blockchain public ledger in blocks
and the people mining these blocks are
called miners
in terms of the mining process also
dogecoin and bitcoin use the same method
to verify and validate the pending
transaction in their networks and that
is proof of work
although ethereum miners also
mine the unvalidated transactions using
the proof of work method it aims to
switch to proof of stake
because it will make its network more
immune to centralization energy
efficient and more vital support for
shared chains
now we have come to the following person
which is monetary policy
monetary policy is known as the process
of drafting announcing and implementing
the plan of actions taken by the
competent monetary authority to control
the money supply and achieve goals that
promote sustainable economic growth
deutsche policy is defined by its block
rewards paid to its miners
whereas
bitcoin policy is defined by two
processes having and block reward
having event is when reward of mining
bitcoin is cut in half
and it also cuts the inflation rate
and the block reward is the number of
bitcoins you get if you successfully
mine a blockchain block
an ethereum's policy is defined as
minimum issuance to secure the network
that is there is a constant trade-off
between the transaction speed and
security
dogecoin's block reward is 10 000 for
mining one block
bitcoin's block reward is 12.5 for
mining each block and which is said to
get reduced to 6.25 by 2024
and ethereum's block reward is two ether
per block
dogecoin takes one minute to generate
one block
bitcoin takes 10 minutes to generate one
block
an ethereum generates one block every 14
seconds
well monetary policies are considered to
be fixed and non-inflationary due to
this over time mining blocks will become
more complex
now moving on to the following
comparison which is transactions
dogecoin is the fastest
and can complete 70 transaction in one
second
and takes just two to three minutes to
confirm a transaction
bitcoin can complete up to five
transaction in one second and takes 10
minutes or more than that to confirm one
transaction
an ethereum can complete 30 transactions
per second and it takes just a few
minutes to confirm it
dogecoin is majorly used for tipping
content creators on social platforms
like reddit and twitter
bitcoin is only used as a superior
alternative for fiat money and is used
primarily for real-world transactions
on the other hand ether the currency of
ethereum acts as the fuel for ethereum
networks
now that we have covered all about
transaction process of these
cryptocurrency
let's have a look at the value of
dogecoin bitcoin and ethereum in today's
date
the value of dogecoin on today's date is
0.2992
dollars
bitcoin being the highest is 34857
an ethereum holds a value of 2356.58
now we have reached the last comparison
of dogecoin bitcoin and ethereum which
is availability
the circulating supply of dogecoin is
1.7 billion
bitcoin very low as compared to dogecoin
is just 21 million in circulation
ethereum on the other hand is said to be
unlimited but till today the circulation
supply of ethereum is 115.6 million
till today 113 billion dogecoin has
already been mined
for bitcoin 18 million bitcoins are
already mined
and for ethereum roughly 36 million
ethereum has already been mined
in this draft you can see the red box on
the right side of the graph shows the
maximum supply of dogecoin
on the extreme left you can see first
the options that
you can use according to your
requirements like if you want to know
about dogecoin you can go for the first
option that is www.dogecoin.com
which will lead you to the official
website of dogecoin if you want to chat
with the executives of coin market
regarding dogecoin then you can go for
the fourth option which is chat
before that is an address for binance
address
through which you can keep a track of
dogecoin's value on that platform and
you can also change it according to your
choice by clicking on more
right beside the more option you can see
the
market cap value of dogecoin which is 38
billion
3849 million
hundred sixty nine thousand ninety eight
it is the total value of dogecoin in
circulation
beside the market cap option you can see
fully diluted market capitalization
which is 38 billion seven hundred
million seven hundred ninety five
thousand nine hundred six
it is the capitalization when max supply
of dogecoin was in circulation and on
the right side just before total supply
you can see the volume of dogecoin one
billion seven hundred seventy nine
million four hundred seventeen thousand
six hundred forty seven
it is the value of dogecoin traded in 24
hours
next is bitcoin
similar to dogecoin you can see the red
box on the right side of the graph shows
the maximum supply of dogecoin
on the extreme left you can see first
the options that you can use according
to your requirement
like if you want to know more about
bitcoin you can go for the first option
that is www.bitcoin.org
which will lead you to the official
website of bitcoin
right beside the more option you can see
the market cap value of bitcoin which is
six hundred fifty one billion seven
hundred thirteen million ten thousand
seven hundred fifty three
it is the total value of bitcoin in
circulation
beside the market cap option you can see
fully diluted market capitalization
that is
732 billion
387 million two hundred sixty two
thousand six hundred ninety
and on the right side just before the
total supply you can see the volume of
bitcoin that is thirty billion two
hundred forty nine million nine hundred
thirty nine thousand eight hundred sixty
five
ethereum is no different from dogecoin
and bitcoin in this also you can see the
total supply of ethereum
also you can visit the official website
of
www.ethereum.org to explore more about
ethereum
you can have a look at the market cap
value of ethereum which is 273 billion
755 million five hundred eighty six
thousand five hundred thirty four
the fully diluted market capitalization
is 273 billion
576 million nine hundred eighty seven
thousand forty nine
the volume of ethereum traded in 24
hours is 24 billion one hundred one
billion seven hundred seventy nine
thousand three hundred forty six but in
the end
all these top cryptocurrencies deutsche
coin bitcoin and ethereum share a few
similarities
like they all are decentralized
all three cryptocurrencies are free from
any third-party interference or any
centralized authority
and can be used to have secure and
independent peer-to-peer transaction
maintaining the anonymity of the user
and proof of work that is all their
transactions are verified and validated
before processing after complete
verification further transaction process
takes place
also all of them have a large network of
independent nodes
meet susan an aspiring painter
she wishes to conduct an online painting
exhibition for all her digital artworks
however as the exhibition is online she
is worried that her paintings won't be
secure as anyone could easily forge or
replicate them
her friend mark came to her rescue with
an idea of nft
he suggested that susan could buy nfts
for all her paintings as nfts are
trustworthy easily transferable and will
also maintain her ownership rights on
her artworks
susan had no idea what nfts were so mark
stepped ahead and explained it to her
nfts turn your digital assets into one
of a kind by creating a unique digital
signature which defines the ownership of
your assets and that can be bought and
sold for real money cryptocurrency or
any other asset like a non-fungible
token aka nft
non-fungible tokens means that they are
not interchangeable and each of them
represents unique assets owned by a
specific person
on the other hand fungible tokens are
interchangeable and can be divided into
smaller units to form the same value
for example a 100 build is fungible as
you can exchange it with five twenty
dollar bills or two fifty dollar bills
but the painting of the last supper is
non-fungible as it cannot be generated
in bulk even if it is copied it will not
be authentic
each nft contains distinguishable
information like who owns the digital
asset and who sold it making them
distinct and easily verifiable
as it is impossible to forge such a
certificate it will secure her
painting's originality
after learning what nft is susan was
curious to know how exactly nft works
nft basically creates a blockchain based
digital certificate for your digital
collectibles including games music art
and many more
this certificate gives your artwork a
unique identity
the underlying technology and the
programming language used by nfts are
the same as other cryptocurrencies such
as blockchain and the programming
language eth or script
nft majorly exists on ethereum
blockchain the distributed public ledger
that records all the transactions
however nft is quite different from
these cryptocurrencies bitcoin and
ethereum are fungible tokens which means
if you trade bitcoin or ethereum for one
another you will have the same value or
item in return basically money
on the other hand nft is a unique token
therefore if you try to trade it you may
end up with something completely
different in your hands
crypto punks is a remarkable example of
nft it enables you to buy sell and store
10 000 collectibles with the proof of
ownership being stored on the ethereum
blockchain
after exploring helen ft's work susan
was convinced and bought nfts for all
her paintings due to this her artworks
were secured from any kind of forgery
and also gave her artworks a particular
value this contributed to increased
sales too as everyone was easily able to
buy the artwork without any fear
all in all her exhibition was a complete
success
similarly nft has proved itself to be a
boon in the lives of many others like
jack dorsey the ceo and co-founder of
twitter with his very first and famous
tweet just setting up my twitter and
vignesh sandarsen famously known as
medicovan who bought 69.3 million
dollars worth of nft art on people
owing to its increasing popularity
people are now willing to pay hundreds
of thousands of dollars for nfps
nft has enhanced media exposure and
special perks for aspiring artists like
susan on social media
this popularity of nft creates new
opportunities for new art platforms
motivating people to buy art from
internet platforms and promoting
copyright or originality of digital
assets
so here's a question for you what makes
any item non-fungible
a exchangeability
b unique digital signature
c tradability
d distributed public ledger please give
it a thought and drop your answers in
the comments section below many experts
in the crypto industry say that around
40 of new crypto users will use nfts as
their entry point as a result of its
growing popularity nft could represent a
more significant part of the digital
economy in the future
in this video we will explore about
shiva innocoin and we'll go through some
of really exciting concepts and
components revolving around it
so how did this shiva inucoin originate
the shiva in a coin was created in
august 2020 by an anonymous person
calling themselves ryoshi an
indian it was intended as an altcoin of
dogecoin which itself was created as an
altcoin of bitcoin
and this meme coin has been named after
the japanese dog breed shiva inu
it feels like the sheba in a coin was
built into existence and is now insanely
popular among major crypto exchanges
through the power of its following crowd
memes
and a very cute dog
now we know how it originated so let's
have a look at what is sheba in a coin
shiva inucoin is a decentralized
community building cryptocurrency or we
can say an experiment
developed within the shiba inu ecosystem
and built on top of the ethereum
blockchain network like many other coins
it is a meme coin launched as a rival of
dogecoin or doge killer
both dogecoin and sheepcoin were made in
a humorous manner but sheepcoin has
already taken over some dogecoin markets
attracting a lot of attention and rising
as a popular choice among investors
especially after such market crash of
cryptos like bitcoin and ethereum
but what is the difference between sheba
and a coin and dogecoin
although both shiva inucoin and dogecoin
are meme coins and share the same tree
of origin both of them differ a lot from
each other at the same time
and the very first difference between
them is the sheep coin is a token and
dogecoin is a currency
let's have a look at more of those major
differences like this
first is development
shiba inu coins or sheep coins are built
on and powered by the ethereum network
while dogecoin has been developed using
the same technology as bitcoin
then is use cases
sheepcoin is still working upon price
more due to its high popularity than
utility
but on the other hand dogecoin has
already established
itself to some extent as a medium of
online payments
there is value according to my coin
market cap
the current value of sheepcoin is
zero zero 0.0000 zero seven three seven
eight dollars
and that of dogecoin is zero point two
six one seven one one dollars
and at last availability the
availability of sheep coin till today is
394 million and for dogecoin it is 130
billion
now this definitely raises a question in
my mind
why is she buying a coin so popular
is majorly popular because of two
reasons
tesla founder elon musk has tweeted
recently expressing that he would like
to own a shiba pub that hyped the crypto
market and its prices rose by 300
percent
on the other hand its prices fell by
around 40 percent after the founder of
ethereum blockchain network with alec
buterin donated 50 trillion shebang
coins to indian government
for corporate relief fund of an indian
crypto entrepreneur sandeep naival
so now that we know about sheba in a
coin and its concepts
let's have a look at what is the future
of shiba you know coins
though sheba coin is only known as a
meme coin its increasing popularity and
people's interest and participating in
it is pointing towards a different but
bright future
according to investing cube.com the
sheba coin is predicted to rise again
although there isn't much movement among
these token and its value active buyers
could help its value rise
the value could rise to 0.000
1040 in a more active buyers market
although it may not appear to be a
significant amount due to its popularity
in future it can have a significant
influence over large investors of the
crypto market
hey everyone
litecoin a cryptocurrency is not a
recent invention it first entered the
market to compete with bitcoin
but litecoin lagged behind the growth of
bitcoin and was overtaken by rival
cryptocurrencies as they joined the
market
but despite the existence of rival
cryptocurrencies bitcoin continues to be
the market leader
however litecoin has a chance of
succeeding in the market
so
considering this hype here is a new
video on litecoin by simply learn to
enlighten you more about its concepts so
let's get started but before moving
ahead please hit the like button and do
subscribe to our youtube channel to
never miss an update from simply learn
well let's have a look at what you are
going to learn in this video about
litecoin
so first i will take you through
the definition of what is litecoin
followed by how it works
then i will let you explore the
differences between litecoin and bitcoin
then i will help you understand what are
the pros and cons of litecoin
then i will explain to you how litecoin
is used
following that i will explain to you how
litecoin is traded
and then i will let you explore why
trade litecoin with cmc markets
and then i will take you through the
factors that affect litecoin
and in the end why should you buy
litecoin
so let's get started with the video
first let me make you understand what is
litecoin
now the native cryptocurrency of the
open source blockchain project litecoin
whose code is a copy of bitcoins is ltc
as the silver to bitcoin's gold litecoin
was created to be more scalable and to
process transactions
considered more quickly than bitcoin in
october 2011 charlie lee a software
engineer who had previously worked at
google
and the cryptocurrency exchange coinbase
announced the creation of the blockchain
on the bitcoin talk forum
now that we know what is litecoin let me
take you through how it actually works
now using an open source cryptographic
technology digital coins are created and
transferred using litecoin it keeps a
decentralized public ledger for all
transactions using blockchain technology
now what is blockchain technology
a shared digital ledger called the
blockchain contains a record of every
litecoin transaction by miners recent
cryptocurrency transactions are compiled
into blocks
after that the blocks are
cryptographically protected before being
connected to the pre-existing blockchain
now litecoin and bitcoin among other
cryptocurrencies also use similar
blockchain technology
now this raises a question that what is
mining
now mining is the process of employing
miners or mining software to secure each
block to the current blockchain the
release of new litecoin units occur when
a block has been secured these units can
be reintroduced into the market by
miners well this raises another question
that how exactly litecoin differs from
bitcoin now this comparison will be made
on a few parameters
first is
coin release date litecoin was launched
on 7 october 2011
whereas bitcoin was released on 9th jan
2009
second is maximum coin supply
there is a limited supply of coins in
circulation for both bitcoin and
litecoin litecoin has 84 million coins
accessible which is almost four times as
many as bitcoin's 21 million
third is average transaction speed
now despite requiring more advanced
equipment than bitcoin to mine which
takes almost 10 minutes blocks in
litecoin are actually generated in 2.5
minutes
up to four times faster
additionally litecoin executes financial
transactions much more quickly and can
handle more of them in the same amount
of time
fourth is
halving having interval for block
rewards their range is based on
basically market supply only
and the last one is mining algorithm a
cryptocurrencies blockchain can grow by
adding new blocks when miners
successfully solve hash functions now
litecoin and bitcoin employ different
mining algorithms script is the hash
function used by litecoin and bitcoin
utilizes sha-256
now let me explain to you the pros and
cons of
litecoin now the popularity of litecoin
started to soar in 2017.
five years later it is still in demand
and sells for over 70 dollars
it has fed better than many of its
rivals during the recent cryptocurrency
sell-off but investments always carry a
risk
it's impressive how relative stability
has held up for litecoin throughout time
though it exhibits steadiness but lacks
the impressive growth that attracts
investors
although the coins are reasonably priced
they are nonetheless more expensive than
most of their rivals
also litecoin's market capitalization is
smaller than other cryptocurrency and it
has lost market share as well
also litecoin is less speculative than
many of the younger coins even if all
cryptocurrency investments are
speculative
the expansion of litecoin may be
constrained by the fact that it is less
scalable than competitive blockchain
like stellar lumens so now that we have
covered the basics of litecoin let me
take you through how litecoin is exactly
used
now due to its strong liquidity litecoin
is a cryptocurrency with simpler trading
actually owners of litecoin will
discover the businesses like newegg
sling tv and even charities like the
american red cross are glad to take
their digital money
to make a payment with ltc you can
alternatively utilize a digital currency
app like bitpay or crypto pay
now you can use the binance app to send
money using ltc if you wish to use it
for peer-to-peer payments now let's see
how litecoin is exactly traded
now the price of one litecoin is
typically indicated against the us
dollar when purchasing it on an exchange
in other words you are selling usd to
purchase ltc if the price of litecoin
increases you can sell it for a profit
because it is now worth more in usd than
when you first purchase it now if you
opt to sell at a lower price and incur a
loss this is what will happen also you
can trade litecoin with cmc markets
using a spread bet or contract per
difference or save the account
this enables you to make price
predictions without actually owning the
cryptocurrency your possession of
litecoin is not transferred instead you
are taking a stake whose value will
fluctuate with changes in the price of
litecoin related to the us dollar
now that you know how litecoin is traded
let me explain to you why litecoin
should be traded with cmc markets so the
first reason is open a long or short
position
now you can trade on increasing and
falling prices with speed
betting at cfds to sell litecoin which
is not available on cryptocurrency
exchanges and you do not need to hold
any second is
efficient use of capital now when you
trade using leverage you merely put up a
small portion of the total trade value
to begin a position with well-known
cryptocurrency exchanges you must
deposit the entire contract's value
remember that both gains and losses will
be amplified and you risk losing more
money than you initially invested third
is no exchange account or wallet there
is no requirement to open an exchange
account or wallet to store the purchase
litecoin in contrast to trading the
underlying cryptocurrency this
eliminates the need to wait for exchange
approval
worry about keeping your wallet secure
and pay fees if you decide to withdraw
money later
fourth is trade with an established
provider cmc markets is a licensed
provider with 29 years in the business
we provide assistance to all of our
customers anytime the markets are open
and fifth is trade responsibility for
most people cryptocurrencies are still
rather new and can be
very unstable they want our clients to
fully access comprehensive instructions
resources to support their trade now
let's have a look at the factors that
actually affect the ltc coin
now similar to bitcoin litecoins would
likely is likely influenced by the
following factors
first is regulation
governments in central banks presented
do not control cryptocurrencies there
are concerns about how this might evolve
over the coming years and it effect on
value
second is
supply
there are only so many litecoins that
can be mined
which is 84 million the rate at which
coins are introduced to the market can
also effectively availability
third is stress
public opinion security durability and
the pricing of competing
cryptocurrencies like bitcoin can all
impact litecoin prices
and fourth is adoption
neither consumers nor businesses have
yet embraced litecoin as a form of
payment however some believe that
blockchain technology has promise and
may one day be more widely used now the
biggest question of concern is
should you buy litecoin
according to blasky or
big ira litecoin might be a good
addition to the portfolio of an
experienced cryptocurrency investor who
values its stability and adaptability
particularly for those who want a
combination store of value asset with
the site bonus of convenient
transactions
so according to some experts litecoin
might be a suitable investment for a
beginner looking to learn the ins and
outs of cryptocurrency trading media
makes the following conclusion about
whether ltc is a good option for your
wallet there are other blockchain
competitors that individuals may pick
from but litecoin still remains a
relevant choice in this video we will
explore some are very interesting and
important aspects of solana crypto
first we will understand what is celana
then we will look into what is a soul
token
or sol token
then we will explore when and how did it
originated
after which we will look into some of
the features of solana
then we will explore what type of
consensus method does solana use
after which we will understand how
solana works
then we will explore the current price
and volume of solana in today's date
after that we will look into the future
of solana holds for itself
and at last we will look into real-life
uses of salana
so without doing much ado let's start
the video
let's explore what is solana
solana is a cryptocurrency
that is used to pay for transactions or
a decentralized computing network
solana attempts to increase blockchain
scalability by combining proof of stake
and proof of history consensus as a
result solana promises to be capable of
processing 50 000 transactions per
second while maintaining
decentralization
now the question arises what is the sl
token or sole token
sonata's ecosystem uses the sl token as
its native currency as a result the
token can be transferred between nodes
in the solana cluster in exchange for
running on-chain programs or certifying
the results
it can also be used to make micro
payments known as lamports
now when we are talking so much about
solana crypto let's also dive down and
explore how and when exactly it came
into existence
anatoly yakovenko established the solana
platform in 2017.
before launching solana yakovenko worked
at balcomb after working as a software
engineer at dropbox
he has a wide spectrum of knowledge
with compression methods
he developed a new method of dealing
with typical throughput difficulties in
the bitcoin and ethereum blockchain
with the help of eric williams and
solana's cto greg fitzgerald
they intended to develop a trustless
distributed protocol with increased
scalability
the team now has experience from leading
companies around the world including
apple google microsoft intel twitter
dropbox and
others now that we know what solana is
and all about its background let me ask
you a question recently solana joined
hands with two foundations to raise a
fund of five million dollars to
encourage the next wave of creators and
fans onto crypto networks so comment
down your answers in the comment section
below
to know the correct answer to this
question watch this video till the end
moving on let's talk about its features
which makes it unique and popular
scalable solana uses proof of history
and a number of other groundbreaking
features to allow the network to scale
at the rate of moore's law
cost for applications with billions of
users solana is designed to keep fees
low
so you will never have to worry about
rising fees as your user base grows
composable
the single global state of solana
guarantees project composability
multiple shards and layer 2 systems
should never be dealt with
so we have heard a lot of references to
proof of history but what exactly is it
that we will discuss within the type of
consensus method solana uses
the solana network which has 200
physically different nodes
can handle a throughput of more than 50
000 dps
when using gpus is one of the most
performant permissionless blockchain
unlike bitcoin which employs the proof
of work algorithm as the system
decentralized clock
solana uses the proof of history
technique
you can use proof of history to
construct historical records that verify
an event occurred at a given point in
time
this algorithm is a verifiable delay
function with a high frequency
this function requires a specific number
of sequential steps to evaluate
each transaction or even that is
examined will be assigned a unique hash
an account that can be verified publicly
and effectively
the count serves as a cryptographic
timestamp
allowing us to determine when each
transaction or event occurred
this provides increased throughput and
efficiency within the solana network
now that we know about its structure and
mechanism let's explore how salana works
now we know solana has built a
one-of-a-kind method for determining the
time of a transaction known as proof of
history
let's see the step-by-step procedure of
how it works
step one input the details of
transactions performed in the network to
its leader
step 2
leader will now efficiently sequence and
organize the messages so that they can
be processed by another nodes
step 3 the leader then executes the
transactions based on the ram's current
state
step 4 the completed states transactions
and signature will then be published by
the leader to the verifiers or
replication nodes
step 5 if the state receives
confirmation the verifiers will perform
the same transactions on their copies of
the state and publish their signatures
and at last step 6 the consensus process
will then use the published
confirmations as votes now that we know
everything about solana let's have a
look at the price and volume of solana
according to market
capitalization the solana network can
process more than 50 000 transactions in
one second
and the current price of it is 30
dollars with a circulating volume of 270
million as well coins
which is quite impressive considering
its time span in market capitalization
as well as compared to other
cryptocurrencies
let's see what future the solana holds
for itself
filana although being a new project has
delivered on its promises of speed and
scalability it's token price has also
done well
attack attracting investors attention
nonetheless the network acceptance and
usage are still in the early stages
we won't know whether solana speed make
a significant difference in the bitcoin
realm
until we witness substantial traffic and
more use cases
having a fast network is beneficial but
the advantages will only occur as more
people utilize it and more use cases
emerge
real-life uses of solana
serum radium bone pedal orca
oxygen and phantom wallet are some of
the recent projects that solana is
working with well this is all about
solana crypto first we will explore what
is binance coin
following that we will understand how it
works
then we will dive down deeper and
explore a very interesting concept
followed by binance which is bnb burning
then we will look at the uses of the
binance coin
followed by its benefits
after that we will come across some
important factors to consider before
investing in the binance coin
and at the end
we will see the pricing dynamics of the
binance coin
the first thing that we are going to
explore is what is binance coin
so binance coin or bnb is a crypto
currency that may be used on the binance
cryptocurrency exchange to trade and pay
fees
as of january 2018 the binance exchange
was the world's largest cryptocurrency
exchange conducting over 1.4 million
transactions
every second
this coin is limited to
200 million bnb tokens and runs on the
ethereum blockchain using the standard
erc 20 protocol
as an incentive binance coin users
receive a reduction in transaction cost
on the binance exchange
other cryptocurrencies such as bitcoin
ethereum litecoin and others can be
exchanged or traded for bnb
now let's move on and see
how it works
bnb is a crypto asset that fluctuates in
value as individuals use and trade it
similar to other digital assets on the
market bnb can be stored in suitable
wallets obtained from crypt exchanges
and sent directly to others for payments
and other purposes
but there is a whole working initiative
behind this process
bedance layer 1 blockchain is merged to
form the bnb chain previously the
binance smart chain and the binance
chain binance designed the blockchain
for best performance when it comes to
trading on chain when building the bnb
chain and binance dex
it is also based on this newly developed
chain furthermore bnb chain transactions
are powered by the bnb gas token which
stands for build and build previously
also known as binance coin
now bnb beacon chain and bnb smart chain
make up the bnb chain the former is
concerned with bnb chain governance
which allows bnb holders to vote and
stick their coins then it's a consensus
layer that's compatible with the
ethereum virtual machine and has
multi-chain hubs
now moving on let's have a look at the
bnb burn concept
binance uses 20 percent of its profit
each quarter to buy back and burn
finance coins completely destroying them
finance has consistently performed
quarterly burns the most recent been on
october 17 2020 which was 13th quarterly
burn
binance will continue to burn bnb coins
every quarter until it has purchased and
destroyed 100 million binance coins or
half of the total supply
finance coins supply is reduced as a
result of the procedure and its rarity
is affected which could affect the
assets value
binance also has a program called the
bnb pioneer burn program which assists
cases when bnb holders have
unrecoverably lost bnb and compensate
them them by reducing the amount from
the next bnb burn
now let's have a look at some of the
uses of the binance coin
the binance coin like other developing
cryptocurrencies has a variety of
applications outside of the binance
exchange including
first is trading
binance coin can be exchanged for other
cryptocurrencies on a variety of
exchanges depending on the exchange's
regulations
next is transaction fees on the binance
exchange
users can use bnb to pay for
transactions on the binance exchange and
earn a hefty discount
next we have is credit card payments on
crypto.com bnb can be used to pay for
crypto credit card bills
next is payment processing merchants can
accept bnb as a form of payments giving
customers more options in terms of
payment methods
next we have is booking travel
arrangements on certain websites bnb can
be used to book hotels flights as well
next is entertainment
now bnb is used for a variety of
purposes in the entertainment industries
from paying for virtual kits to
purchasing lottery tickets as well
next in the line is investment
binance coin can be used to invest
in stocks etfs and other assets on a
variety of platforms
and at last is loans and transfers on
some platforms bnb can be used as a
collateral for loans there are also apps
that allow users to use binance coin to
split bills and pay friends and
relatives
so now that we have covered the basics
of the binance coin let's have a look at
some of its benefits that makes it
unique
starting with
quick transactions
when you trade on the exchange with bnb
you'll have access to the platform
property matching engine which can
handle up to 1.4 million orders per
second
finding the appropriate transaction is
always possible and using bnb makes it
even easier and more reliable
next is secure and trustworthy
binance already has millions of
cryptocurrency users and dealers who
rely on the platform and believe in the
security and protection aspects of this
exchange to keep your funds safe the
exchange uses a multi-cluster and
multi-tire system framework as well as
the secure assets funds for users
next is trade multiple cryptocurrencies
you can trade more than 150
cryptocurrencies on the exchange with
bnb thanks to a rapid secure and low
cost transaction matching technology
aside from that bnb has its own trading
pair to fulfill your individual trading
needs there's no need to seek elsewhere
moving ahead is trading discount
you can also get a 50 discount on your
trading charge if you use bnb with
traditional payment methods if you buy
10 000 worth of coins you'll be charged
10
and if you use bnb though the trading
charge is cut in half so you'll just
have to spend five dollars
next is
spending binance coin you can utilize
bnb in a variety of ways in addition to
having a smooth experience within the
binance ecosystem and receiving
transaction fee discounts
several service providers particularly
in the travel and hotel industries
accept it using bnb you can purchase
dinner or a new phone as well
now let's have a look at some of the
factors that you should consider before
investing in binance coin
now binance coins can be used to invest
in some icos listed on binance launchpad
program the binance exchange will
publish new cryptocurrencies and the use
of binance coins will provide a seamless
marketplace for trading a range of
virtual tokens
binance will eventually become the
decentralized binance exchanges
principle currency
the visa debit card of monaco the
world's first payment and cryptocurrency
platform and the platform's mobile app
also support binance coin
now as we are talking about investments
let's have a look at the peak at bnb
pricing and dynamics
bnb's pricing has traditionally varied
in a similar way to the price of other
crypto assets traded on the market
binance coins market capitalization has
increased over time topic 70 billion
dollars bnb was also sold for around
0.10
per token during finances ico
today the current value of bnb is
286.67 dollars with the market
capitalization of 46 billion 801 million
200 10 081 dollars
bnb has seen a tremendous increase in
value since its ico reaching a high of
more than 600 per coins at time is it
wise to invest in binance coin
well if perches join and sold at the
right times it's conceivable and its
past price growth resulted in profit
however only time can tell where the
price of bnb will go in the future
first we will understand what is ripple
followed by what is xrp
then we will see the working of ripple
then we will learn how to mine xrp after
that we will have a comparison between
bitcoin and ripple then we will explore
the pros and cons of ripple
after which we will see how you can
actually use ripple
followed by we will see how can we buy
ripple
and in the end we will see if it is a
good investment or not
so let's get started with the video
first let's understand what is ripple so
the firm behind x rp is ripple
which is a payment settlement systems
and currency network that can handle
transactions all across the world
basically it acts as a trusted
intermediary between two parties in a
transaction
as the network can be immediately
validated that the transaction was
completed successfully
ripple can ease the exchange of a wide
range
of fiat currencies and cryptocurrencies
including bitcoin
so when users utilize a network to make
a transaction the network takes a modest
charge in the form of xrp
and ripple was built from the ground up
to be a swift a leading money transfer
network successor or to otherwise
replace sentimental layer between large
financial institutions so this raises
the question of what is exa so let's
have a look at it the x rp ledger
created by jade mikhail arthur brito and
david schwartz is a blockchain that runs
xrb
mckillib and brito would go on to form
ripple which would employ xrp to enable
network transactions
you can acquire xrp as an investment
crypto to trade from other
cryptocurrencies or as a way to fund
ripple network transactions
xrp's blockchain in particular drifted
from that of most other cryptocurrencies
other cryptocurrencies give anyone who
can solve difficult equations quickly
access to their transaction ledgers and
verification processes
ripple transactions on the other hand
are safe since the majority of ledger
holders must agree to the verification
before they can be added also the ripple
network which employs xrp
is somewhat centralized and uses a
consensus protocol this means
while anyone can download its validation
software it has its own node list that
consumers can use to validate
transactions based on which participants
they believe are least likely to cheat
them
so now that we know the basics of ripple
and xrp let's have a look at working of
ripple
to verify transactions the xrp
cryptocurrency employs a consensus
protocol validators verify that proposed
transactions are valid by comparing them
to the most recent version of the xrp
ledger
now a tran transaction must be accepted
by the majority of validators in order
to be verified once it's verified the
transaction is then added to the
blockchain so now that we know it's
working let's have a look at how ripple
can be mined by its users ripples or
excel is created using a crypto ledger
that is akin to blockchain technology
and is federated by financial
institutions and payment processor
networks
while it is true that ripple xrp cannot
be mined by miners it is technically
viable to do it using other
cryptocurrencies
so one of the most viable techniques for
mining xrp is to mine other
cryptocurrencies such as bitcoin and
ethereum and then transfer the mine
crypto for ripple through exchanges
and that's how the mining is done
so as we have discussed all the basics
of ripple let's dive down deeper and
have a look at how it differs from
bitcoin
to verify transactions and distribute
new currencies bitcoin employs mining
participants set up mining devices to
solve complex mathematical equations
with the first person to solve the
equation winning the right to add a
block of transaction to bitcoin's
network
then participants receive bitcoin
rewards for each block they add in the
exchange for bitcoin mining
whereas the consensus protocol used by
xr plane confirms transactions for a
transaction to be accepted it must
receive the approval of a majority of
validators who actually review it then
bitcoin transaction confirms can take
several minutes and are associated with
significant transaction charges due to
the intricate
and expensive nature of mining utilized
in the cryptocurrency but on the other
hand xrp transactions are instantly
confirmed and have really cheap
transaction fees the user is charged a
small amount of xrp each time a
transaction is completed on the ripple
network
now the supply of bitcoin is limited to
21 million which means there will be
never more than 21 million bitcoin the
artificial scarcity of 12 bitcoin has
sparked investor interest in the
currency's potential as a safe haven but
in contrast at the time of introduction
one billion xrp was free mined and
progressively distributed onto the
market by the company's major investors
next we have when miners discovered
bitcoins they are released and added to
the network they have no set release
date and their supplies is largely
determined by network speeds and the
difficulty of the algorithm used to
create coins
on the other hand the release of xrp is
controlled by a smart contract according
to an inbuilt smart contract ripple is
expected to distribute a maximum of 1
billion xrp tokens per month
so the current circulation is 55 billion
till now
so this was all about the difference
between bitcoin and ripple
and i'm pretty sure that till now you
have understood all the basic knowledge
about ripple so let's move ahead and
look into some of the pros and cons
of ripple
though xrp transactions are quick and
inexpensive ripple's consensus protocol
is perhaps less secure than other crypto
transaction processing technologies
next is even though financial
organizations are already using ripple's
payment network ripple's financial
partners primarily use triple net rather
than xrp cryptocurrency
next we have is small company owners and
individuals who can utilize xrp to make
safe money transactions
yet because it is administered by a
private corporation and because of the
sec litigation ripple has sparked the
debate
and for foreign currency transfers xrp
can be utilized as a bridge currency but
in the united states buying serpi is
quite challenging so now that we know
its pros and cons also let's have a look
how you can actually use ripple
xrp can be used in the same way as any
digital currency for transaction or as a
possible investment
other sorts of transactions such as
currency exchange potentially be
processed using the ripple network for
example instead of dealing with the
currency conversion directly through a
bank or money changing exchange
you may first exchange your us dollars
for xrp on the ripple network and then
use them to buy euros rather than paying
the hefty cost that banks and money
transmission businesses may demand this
can be a lot fast and less expensive
option
so now that we know everything about
ripple let's explore how can we actually
buy ripple
so all you need is sign up for an
account on an exchange that sells
ripples xrp cryptocurrency to buy it
then using any of the exchanges allowed
payment methods buy it here are a few
places where you can get xrp q coin
uphold and coin mama
now the question is
is ripple a good investment
so
xrp
is a risky investment that is not for
the faint of art
however if you feel ripple will succeed
as a payment system it may be worthwhile
to invest in xrp so just be sure you're
not gambling with money you can't afford
to lose
well this was all about what is ripple
recently you all must have noticed that
the crypto market has caused quite a
buzz in social media and other online
forums and perhaps even in your dinner
time conversations
but what is all this commotion about
this is about the recent downfall of
cryptocurrencies in the crypto market
in this video we will let you through
some very important aspects of this
phenomenon of cryptocurrency
first of all we will understand what
cryptocurrency and crypto market are
after that we will understand how the
market works
then we will look into the reasons for
the market crash of cryptocurrency
and how it has affected people at all
levels
then we will figure out the factors that
can help the market to grow again
and at last we will look into the future
of cryptocurrency and trip to market
so let's start with the very first
aspect that is what cryptocurrency and
crypto market are
a cryptocurrency is a kind of virtual or
digital currency that works on
blockchain technology a public ledger
enforced by a distributed network of
computers
it works as a medium of exchange online
to buy goods and services and make
payments
like for example bitcoin ethereum
dogecoin these are some of the popular
cryptocurrency
cryptocurrency is decentralized and free
from any third-party interference
which means it is not issued or
controlled by any government or central
authority
the crypto in cryptocurrency stands for
cryptography which uses encryption and
decryption to secure the data
crypto market is where you can trade
cryptocurrency cryptocurrency trading is
an act of speculating the price movement
of cryptocurrency without taking
ownership of the underlying coins
through a trading account or by buying
and selling the underlying coins through
an exchange
you can buy cryptocurrency if you think
it will rise in value or sell them if
you think it will fall
now let's understand how it works
the price of crypto currency is quoted
in traditional currencies such as the us
dollar and you never take ownership of
the cryptocurrency itself
one can buy and sell at cryptocurrency
through their trading account or via
exchange which helps them speculate on
whether the chosen cryptocurrency will
rise or fall in value
both buy and sell are leveraged products
which means you only need to put up a
small amount as a deposit known as
margin to gain total exposure to the
underlying market
your profit or loss is majorly
calculated based on the total size of
your position
so leverage can affect your profits as
well as your losses if the market moves
against you
so that makes me question what the
reasons behind the market crash of
cryptocurrency are
on 19th may 2021 the crypto market saw a
massive drop in prices or crypto
currencies including bitcoin ethereum
and bnt crashing up to 30 percent within
a span of just 24 hours
this came in the backdrop of the chinese
regulators announcing a ban of
cryptocurrency
china has banned payment companies and
financial institutions from providing
any services such as registration
trading clearing and settlement related
to cryptocurrency transactions
this announcement made by china broke
the markets back
and then the panic increased because
tesla announced that they would not
favor bitcoin on environmental concerns
anymore therefore they will not accept
any payment made by bitcoin
and also there are rumors of irs
investigation into the largest crypto
exchange platform binance which also has
weakened investors resolution to invest
more in crypto market
now we know the reasons behind the
crypto market crash so let's take a look
at how it has affected people at all
levels
the crypto market means different things
to different people it is an object of
speculation that consumes almost all the
media coverage
about the space to many people
for them the day crypto market crashed
was a black day as they faced a
tremendous loss of the leverage invested
in cryptocurrencies
even the bloomberg galaxy crypto index
plunged 19.2 percent in its worst slide
in more than a year
and to others the crypto market is more
than a speculative instrument for them
this incident proved to be a huge
opportunity as they got a chance to
uncover problems of the system of the
crypto market like high fees to trade at
the most crucial moments and find
solution to these problems by adding
more capacity and efficiency to the
system
so now we have covered everything about
the market crash of cryptocurrency let's
dive into the factors that can help the
market to grow again
despite their dramatic downturns these
cryptocurrencies have consistently
recovered from their downtime
people in the crypto market systems have
termed this decline as a short-term
correction
long-term investors like microstrategy
call this crash a buying opportunity of
these cryptocurrencies and
is investing more to stabilize them
many people believe that what we
witnessed in the last few days was the
liquidation of the leverage long
positions followed by a panic sell-off
and is considered a very normal
phenomenon in thin markets like
cryptocurrency
they believe that this situation can be
thought down by extensive adoption of
cryptocurrency and constant
participation in the crypto market
well this whole scenario makes me
question what the future cryptocurrency
and crypto market holds
cryptocurrency is a highly speculative
and volatile investment and it may or
may not succeed over time
therefore there is no guarantee for
these cryptocurrencies that all will
always recover from this type of market
crashes
a few experts of the crypto market
saying that investors should hold a
long-term view of the digital assets
market
as they will bounce back swiftly
also small investors should be better
off staying away from the market as this
current volatility can be overwhelming
for them
and some experts suggest that holding on
to these cryptos will be a wise option
and small investors should buy these
cryptos slowly and steadily through a
systematic plan
therefore if you're thinking about
investing in cryptocurrency be sure you
know what you're getting into although
the crypto market is lucrative
keep in mind that there's always a
chance that sometimes cryptocurrencies
are not able to bounce back let's have a
look at the top crypto trading platform
in 2022 but before diving right into the
list let's have a quick and crisp
understanding of what crypto trading
actually means
so
taking a financial on the price
direction of individual cryptocurrencies
against the dollar or against any other
cryptocurrency is what crypto trading is
all about cfds or contract for
difference are a popular way of trading
cryptocurrencies because they offer more
flexibility
leverage and the ability to trade both
long and short positions
also it's essential to consider things
like supported assets fees
payment methods and security when
considering a cryptocurrency trading
platform
so we have also considered these factors
to give you a better idea of which
platform will be the best for you
so now that we have a basic idea what
crypto trading is let's dive into the
list of top crypto trading platforms for
2022.
the first platform in the list is
coinbase
for many first-time cryptocurrency
buyers coinbase has become the go to
exchange the platform has the appearance
and feel of an online banking tool which
the majority of consumers are already
familiar with
making the transfer to crypto investing
simple
coinbase is the finest cryptocurrency
exchange overall as well as the best
cryptocurrency exchange for beginners it
supports a huge variety of
cryptocurrencies and provide a high
level of security
it's also wonderful alternative for
expert traders because it offers an
advanced trading platform coinbase pro
in addition to being a beginner friendly
platform
so let's have a look at the account
prerequisites for coinbase
it supports more than 150 plus cryptos
for trading with the transaction fee
ranging between zero percent to zero
point six zero percent also the minimum
deposit of purchase price should be at
least two dollars
now let's have a look at its pros and
cons
coinbase offers a large volume of
cryptocurrencies
what to trade for it provides more
experience to beginners as well as offer
easy trading to advance members of it it
also provides liquidity and ease on its
platform
now cons
the customer service provided by them is
not up to the mark as well as
coinbase.com
is an institutional account which means
you don't have access to your private
keys
moving on next we have is crypto.com
crypto.com offers a diverse digital
asset ecosystem that includes its own
blockchain the crypto.org
a native token known as cro a crypto
visa card yield generating crypto
products and more it was chosen as the
top mobile crypto exchange application
because it offers a comprehensive
digital asset trading and investing
environment that you can access from
your smartphone
now let's have a look at the account
prerequisites for crypto.com
it supports more than 250 plus cryptos
for trading with a transaction fee
ranging between 0.04
to 0.40
also the minimum deposit or purchase
price should be at least one dollar
now let's have a look at its pros and
cons
crypto.com supports a huge range of
cryptocurrencies to trade for and other
crypto related services like payments
and asset avoid evaluation
now moving towards cons it fees is
relatively high also the customer
service is a little poor and stagnant
next in the list we have is gemini
gemini stands out as a sign that
prioritizes security and compliance
hot wallet insurance is provided by the
new york based exchange to ensure that
user funds are protected in the event of
a security comprise because it has
comprehensive security protocols ensures
customer cash and is soc two certified
gemini is the most
secure crypto exchange
now let's have a look at the account
prerequisites for gemini
it only supports 75 plus cryptos for
trading with the transaction fee ranging
between
0.99 percent to 2.99
also it has a minimum deposit
or purchase price and it varies
according to the asset invested
now let's have a look at its pros and
cons
gemini is available in all 50 states of
united states with extremely liquid
market
all the funds stored in the wallets are
perfectly insured and secure also if ui
is pretty strong
coming to its cons
many traders in it have high cost also
as compared to other crypto trading
platforms it supports less
cryptocurrencies as well now moving on
to the next platform in the list we have
binance
the most appealing feature of binance is
it's low cost when compared to other
exchanges beginners will appreciate the
simple buy sell option while
professional traders will appreciate the
in-depth basic and advanced trading
platforms
now let's have a look at the account
prerequisites for binance it supports
more than 500 plus cryptos for trading
with a transaction fee ranging between
zero point one zero percent to zero
point five zero percent also it has no
minimum deposit or purchase price of
fifty dollars
now let's have a look at its pros and
cons
binance purchase piece is non-immediate
as well as instant also a huge variety
of points is available on its platform
along with this it offers various other
services
coming to the cons once the verification
of account was hampered it is not yet
available in united states and its
corporate structure is pretty opaque
next we have is
kraken kraken is one of the world's most
well-known bitcoin exchanges in the
early days of the crypto market it
established itself as the go-to site for
professional investors it has retained
its image as a trustworthy and
professional trading venue
it has some of the lowest fees in the
cryptocurrency exchange world it's also
our top pick for experienced traders as
it allows leverage and futures trading
as well as enables complex order types
now let's have a look at the account
prerequisites for kraken
basically it supports more than 120 plus
cryptos for trading with a small
transaction fee ranging between
0.00 to zero point two six percent also
it has minimum deposit or purchase price
of minimum one dollar
now let's have a look at its pros and
cons
kraken supports a large range of
cryptocurrency with minimum fee and also
provide the traders more market
liquidity
coming to the cons not all states and us
can accept it
as options for financing your account
are limited
next in the list we have bitstamp
bitstamp is one of the most
cost-effective bitcoin exchanges it
offers a simple pricing structure that
bases your trading fees on your 30-day
trading volume
for users with less than
ten thousand dollars on bitstamp the
highest trading cost is merely 0.50
with its pros and cons
in terms of trading fees bitstamp is one
of the top cryptocurrency exchanges
tradeview a real-time trading platform
is also available this version contains
more extensive charting and trading
forms this platform offers a diverse
range of points including many of the
most popular as well as some
lesser-known cryptos
and the cons are while bitstem offers a
good selection of cryptocurrencies there
are significant ones that aren't
available
its bitstam make program which allows
you to stay crypto allows you to earn
passive money but there are a few
drawbacks as well in 2015 hackers were
successfully in launching a phys fishing
salt against bitstam workers which
resulted in a security breach
following bitstamp we have bitmap
bitmap is a global bitcoin exchange with
over 180 locations
users can purchase sell and store over
1000 different digital currencies and
tokens
investors wishing to add newly launched
or obscure crypto assets to the
portfolios while likely find what
they're searching for on this exchange
as it offers more assets and trading
pairs than its market leading
counterparts let's have a look at the
account prerequisites for bitmap
bitmap offers 1000 plus cryptos for
trading with a very small transaction
fee that ranges between
0.045 percent to 0.25
also coming to its minimum deposit or
purchase the price is 30
when purchasing via bitmap
for spot trading the price is not
published yet
now let's have a look at its pros and
cons
bittmart supports a huge variety of
cryptocurrency and provide great
opportunities to earn cryptocurrency as
well
along with that it provides an easy
trade option for buying and selling
cryptocurrencies
now moving on to the cons
there was a large scale hack on this
platform in 2021 also the customer
reviews are average for this application
moving on next in our list is q coin
q coin is a third-party cryptocurrency
exchange that lets you buy sell and
trade a variety of cryptocurrencies
the founder's goal was to provide a
simple and secure platform for people
all around the world
to exchange a variety of digital
currency cue coin has a large number of
cryptocurrencies to choose from and has
minimal cost when compared to other
cryptocurrency exchanges
staking leverage futures and
peer-to-peer trading are all supported
which may appeal to more experienced
users
now let's have a look at the account
prerequisites for q coin
so q coin offers only up to 28 cryptos
for trading with a very small
transaction fee ranging between 0.00 to
0.10
also coming to its minimal deposit or
purchase the price is merely 5
now let's have a look at its pros and
cons
cue coin maintains the anonymity of the
user while trading yet it offers secure
platform as well also it supports
multiple cryptocurrencies
coming to the cons the trading volume of
cryptocurrencies are pretty low and also
during heavy traffic it can face some
serious issues
following q coin in our list we have
cash app
now individuals in the united states and
the united kingdom can use the cash app
to send spend deposit and invest money
an essentially a peer-to-peer payment
app with an investment component through
the cash app
users can also invest in stocks etfs and
bitcoin it enables you to purchase sell
and store bitcoin
from your smartphone itself in a more
simpler and safer manner
now
looking at its account prerequisites
like we discussed cash app is only a
bitcoin exchange application so it
supports only one cryptocurrency that is
bitcoin
the transaction fee varies depending on
the action
also the minimum deposit of purchase is
just one dollar
now let's have a look at its pros and
cons
cash app provides an easy access ui and
quick withdrawal from its wallets
other than this it also supports bitcoin
lighting network it's a second layer
bitcoin technology that employs micro
payment channels to increase the
blockchain's ability to perform
transactions more quickly
moving on to the cons it only supports
bitcoin the wallet is always volunteered
and it has limits on everything the
deposits sales and other items
so now we have reached a
last
crypto trading platform in our list
which is
bisch
bish is the peer-to-peer cryptocurrency
trading platform that allows individuals
from all over the world to trade a
variety of digital currencies and tokens
customers are not required to complete a
know your customer or kyc identity
verification process
and this trading platform is not
restricted to users in specific
jurisdictions
it lets users to buy and sell bitcoin
and other cryptocurrencies with a
variety of payment options such as bank
wire transfers ach transfers and cash
deposits as well
now let's have a look at its
prerequisites
bish currently supports 100 plus
cryptocurrencies for transaction with
transaction price ranging between 0.10
to 0.70
and there is no minimal deposit or
purchase required
now moving on to its pros and cons
this bish application is available
throughout the world and anyone can use
it
it provides a high end security and
doesn't requires any sort of kyc or id
verification
and it provides almost 50 payment
options for crypto transactions
moving on to the cons the speed of the
transactions are pretty low and low
trading
values are also possible as it doesn't
consist of any minimal deposit or
purchase also it is not a great option
for active trading
and with that we have come to the end of
this video on cryptocurrency full course
i hope you found it interesting
if you have any questions about the
topics covered in this video please ask
away in the comment section below
our team will help you solve your
queries thanks for watching stay safe
and keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here
you